foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob and
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm
oh we missed it
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be the match for some this is
familiar ground oh my goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby exhausting every last
resource the battles will be Electric
the moves will be fast this game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he grabs
his head he can't believe it he just
gave away the pawn the 2022 speed Chess
Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
feed Chess Championship we have yet
another Super exciting match for you
today as nihal sarin faces off dingliren
in a cgc rematch bringing you the
commentary I'm GM Daniel naritzki once
again alongside International Master
Levy Rosman Levy good morning to you
happy Friday I think it's Friday took me
a while to figure that out how are you
feeling
uh yeah it is Friday because and I know
this because on Friday I have to put out
our garbage and recycling and uh
yesterday I tried to do that like five
times yesterday felt like a Friday but
today actually is Friday and I get to
spend it in the morning watching I think
our closest matchup thus far of this
entire event on paper more on that later
I'm just super excited to see the house
star and back in action and anytime we
get to watch dingley Run play it's
obviously a pleasure it most certainly
is let's start with the bracket we'll be
looking at this bracket a lot and as
I've said many times it is a feast for
the eyes the most lopsided match
surprisingly enough uh features that
obscure player over in the top right who
will be facing another obscure player in
the round of eight Carlson carwana but
wherever you turn you have Incredibly
Close matches aronian and draken went to
overtime yesterday Levy Hikaru Nakamura
with a resounding defeat over David
paravian who nonetheless I think should
hold his head up high he did his best
but some of these guys in the SEC are
just they're just sharks
yeah I mean there's uh no I I don't know
how to say it you shouldn't really be
sad that you don't you know score that
many points against Hikaru obviously
Hikaru was a massive favorite in that
matchup I think David first of all in
qualifying it was already razor thin
right but he made it over I believe it
was Tuan minlay and then he ultimately
gets a couple of points off of Hikaru
but yeah I mean like when you talk about
a quarterfinal these are literally the
biggest names and I think we just have
to get used to something I think we have
to get used to seeing a bracket of the
best players in the world plus nihal
sarin who is very quickly emerging as
one of the best rapid Blitz and bullet
chess players in the world we'll see if
his classical holds up as well but he is
known I think as the number one Indian
chess Prodigy in these faster time
controls so right now it's the same
thing at the cgc it was all the guys
that we've been seeing for the last half
a decade if not 10 years and nihal his
SCC record is absolutely amazing
multiple time winner of the jscc he's
beaten grishook he's developed an
incredible track record but today will
he meet his match in World Championship
Challenger ding liren now they of course
have met once in a marquee matchup in
the cgc and in that match nihal
absolutely ran ding out of the gym Levy
those were your words and I think those
were very accurate words dingley Ren
he's not usually someone you think
really has a chip on his shoulder but I
feel like this match is going to be
different
this match definitely will be different
that was a of course a rapid matchup
which you could even argue was supposed
to favorite ding right you're supposed
to always say all these young guys
they're just good with a minute on the
clock no that was a 15-minute matchup
they both had 50 minutes in every single
game and nehal was clutched defensively
and just super sharp when he needed to
be uh in the critical moments against
ding but I mean yeah they've never
played Blitzer Bullet Head to Head which
I feel like again we're seeing in a lot
of nihal's player cards it's like these
guys just haven't played them they have
no read on him so the player that's
played nehal the most is Anish giri at
this point he probably played him like
45 50 times but not ding
uh yeah no it's it's amazing to see
these new matchups these battles of
generations and it's a total Black Box
we don't know what we're gonna get and
that makes it exciting a quick run
through of the format ladies and
gentlemen the SEC is a 16 player
knockout oh any players have already
been knocked out players score
cumulative points across three-time
controls until time runs out the overall
match time is three hours and in the
event of a tie we have four games of one
plus one now there's 90 minutes of five
plus one followed by an hour of three
minutes plus one and that concludes the
match with 30 minutes of bullet one
minute plus one second increment so
there's increment throughout and Levy as
we have discussed now so many times one
plus one is a completely different game
from OnePlus zero and the second thing
that I'll run by you is that five plus
one is basically classical chess yes it
is
um then what is 15 plus two in the cgc
right I mean it's it's a weird one yeah
blizz games are supposed to be
fast-paced uh potentially tactical and
time is a factor not really in five plus
one honestly like it really just does
seem like the pet the player that's
better at the long time control should
have the advantage but mean how won this
matchup the last time that there was
long time control involved which was 15
minute chess so right now I think a lot
of things look to be in his favor what
doesn't look to be in his favor is that
dingley Wren is the second best chess
player in the world according to the
classical chess rankings and he's
literally playing for the crown in three
months like he's going to play or four
months which got announced by the way
April I believe 2023 is one of the world
championship is so he's playing a guy
it is about damn time speaking of
um so I this is a fascinating one and
you know like does nehal have any
fatigue or is he young three days
removed from uh just a match that
probably took three months off the
commentators lives like well yeah and 10
years off the players lives yeah I don't
know man I don't know it's super it's
super tense super exciting to see I
don't know what to expect I mean
um I think we have a card coming out
I'll let you I'll let you take us there
but this is just the closest match I've
ever seen
it just smells like a post match I mean
you could just feel it in the air and
look at the smarter chest stats four and
a half four and a half four and a half
four and a half I feel like I'm gonna be
saying that number so many times and
smarter chess predicts a win for
knee-haul by one point in the bullet
segment and I think that's as Fair as a
prediction can possibly get 49 to 51.
this is the closest that a smarter chess
prediction Levy has ever been to 50 50.
smarter chess simply does not know who
is going to win and can you really blame
him that that's confirmed right like I'm
not imagining that this has to be the
closest C uh no cgc obviously but
speechless Championship matchup that has
ever taken place it literally comes down
to one game it does not get any closer
it looks like smarter just pick these
numbers out of the air like it could
have been 5149 the other way exactly I
mean I I don't know I just have no idea
like will the Wi-Fi for ding hold up
right we gotta count these wild cards as
well oh my goodness just shockingly
close matchup and that's not you know a
rhetorical statement because ding he has
had his share of problems with his
internet
um you never know if these players are
in a hotel or if they're on an airplane
or if they're in you know a NASA space
shuttle you just never know so hopefully
ding uh you know everything holds up for
both of these players but the community
the community also believes that this
match is going to be as close as it gets
Levy this is incredible 49 51 in the
community predictions as well love to
see thousands of you filling out your
brackets by the way thank you for doing
that thank you for being engaged 44
predicted this matchup to happen
and again it's only 51.49 by a total of
13 brackets
13 brackets and it could have been tied
oh my God that's completely nuts ah I
don't know man I don't know I'm getting
some Al Gore Bush Vibes this is
incredible yeah seriously oh my gosh I
I but but in what what is going to be
the trajectory they're not gonna make
draws like are they just gonna go back
and forth that means that they're gonna
win consistently with a certain color
like if I win with white that means you
win the next one with white so what's
gonna happen who's gonna be beating who
with what color is there going to be a
three-game lead and then a three-game
comeback who is more likely to give up a
lead in this match versus the other I
don't know what the storyline has to be
to get us to a 14 and a half 13 and a
half score line I mean it's literally
razor thin
no it's it's unbelievable I think we're
gonna get a lot of back and forth action
a lot of alternating wins let's take a
quick look at their chess.com Blitz
insights you can see that crazy average
accuracy for dingly Wren I mean the guy
is a machine and he has been so
consistently underrated in his ability
to play Blitz the guy is fast he doesn't
panic when he's low on time and we take
a lot of these things for granted but
dingley Wren he might not be the most
experienced player I mean look at that
disparity in total games maybe that's
something that nihal sarin has to try to
harness in his favor although I don't
know how he's going to do that but
nonetheless dingley Ren Levy is a
full-fledged Blitz expert and just like
Fabiano caruana chess players are very
prone to these misconceptions and these
preconceived notions about how fast or
how slow these players are
yes the lost by flag situation is kind
of insane yeah that doesn't help the
cause yeah yeah I mean that just that
really just shows you that that there is
a legitimate chance ding in a Time
scramble uh combined with potential
internet problems uh it could be a
factor um according to these stats has
played a 18
500 and is that 49 games more than
dingley run gosh that's that's a lot
it's a lot of Chess on chat that was
some pretty good Earth arithmetic there
you're warmed up for the match I think
you're ready yeah I am I am ready
um wow we're we have game game one
coming your way uh they do not have 10
minutes they will have five
and I believe higher rated player gets
the white pieces yeah that's the uh
that's the SEC format so
that's the rule and nihal has been
sticking religiously to his London butt
the higher rated player in this case of
course is dingley Wren he gets the white
pieces ladies and gentlemen seat belts
fastened we are off and a surprise on
move one dingley Wren plays E4 and I
think nihal is surprised as well
uh
when is the last time dingley Wren
played E4
yeah was it like when Gangnam Style came
out or like what what Milestone or
Landmark was it 2013 like I legitimately
don't know and this is a this is a very
trendy line right now in the in the Karo
Khan like this uh C5 Knight F3
um Grand Masters have kind of gone here
to try to explore these positions a
little bit more uh but black is complete
is completely fine just a little passive
yeah black is fine but has to tread very
carefully on the king side and you get
these structures also in the French
um and just like in the French black
does have problems Levy with this light
squared Bishop you sometimes see black
going A5 Bishop A6 trying to trade the
bishop off sometimes the bishop just
Parks itself on B7 and later on you can
push the C Pawn but U-Haul going for the
first idea here
yes uh very interesting to see that
nehal's weapon of choice against E4 was
going to be the Cairo like I wonder if
he showed up to the smash and said okay
if ding plays the move E4 I'm gonna play
the Karo Khan I'm not gonna play E5 and
you know this could be a spot where ding
uh was just is not convinced by Neil's
repertoire right that was the whole
storyline in the cgc uh for those that
don't remember it was that how it could
be potentially exploitable if you will
with the black pieces and so maybe maybe
ding thought he was going to face a
modern is that far-fetched because I
think uh nehal kept playing that against
the niche kept playing G6 stuff
yeah no I think a modern can be expected
also as the time control shortens if
ding continues to play E4 and if
something doesn't work out in the Cairo
nihal has shown Levy a willingness to
change his openings at the drop of a hat
but look at that move by dig h2h4 of
course you couldn't take that pawn
because of the fork on A4 forking the
king and the Knight on the other side of
the board
um
I'm trying to find games that Ding diren
played with E4 and I can't
yeah I don't think he's ever played it I
think he's played DeForest in his birth
yeah like yeah I think there was a
Sorting Hat put on him and they were
like you got to play an opening and he's
I mean I'm sure he's he he he's had to
play it at some point right I'm still
trying to scour the internet to find it
I'm I'm mind blown I know it's crazy is
he actually gonna prepare it for nepo
could that really be a thing this
definitely raises some questions about
the direction in which ding's opening
repertoire has has gone but the downside
Levy could be that he's a little bit
less familiar with some of the typical
middle games that arise out of E4
structures you might be like ding less
familiar the guy is 2800 you know what
are you talking about still it's not
just about opening preparation it's also
about just familiarity with the pun
structures and the types of tactical
features that arise in these typical
middle games and here you can see ding
already falling seriously behind on the
clock but I like his position
yeah I like his position too it feels
very airy on the queen side for um
for black uh
and I I mean I like the two on one which
I feel like if you're gonna you know two
on one of course being that if you
simplify white we'll have a pass pawn
and it's felt much more than the D5 Pawn
for black which really is an asset on D5
only I mean it's not an asset anywhere
else it's going to be captured the
second it moves forward so uh I do like
ding's position but it's still in the
balance and you know different players
if a different player was seated with
the black pieces I might I might really
like White's position but nehal just has
a way of figuring things out
and yeah he really does it's important
also to say that Ding has played E4
online but over the board I I don't know
the last time I mean he he plays E4
sometimes in these matches
um but uh like if you look at a database
of his online and over the board games
to find a game that he's been on the
white side of akaro Khan
like I don't know if that's ever
happened so just interesting isn't it
crazy it could be 2800 and never play E4
this just blows my mind it should lead
to one of those memes you know like why
have you looking for ding games in the
Karo Khan from the white side then 2025
still looking and then your hair is gray
you know and your kids are behind you
still looking to do this later I just
went to it's a chessgames.com and I
dingly Ren has had
four games on the white side of a Karo
Khan two have been against Magnus in the
2020 online 2019 it happened once and
the last time before that was 2001
he hadn't been on the white side 2001 oh
my God 18 years he had a gap can you
imagine how much Theory got developed in
those years
2001 we were still like you know picking
at each other with stone axes basically
yeah in chess terms it's a miracle games
that went past move 10 you know we were
just getting checkmated using a chess
base 4 on our compact computers you know
loading up Fritz too
back when Fritz would uh back when Fritz
would uh talk to you you remember those
days my opponent is taking back moves
and it was the coolest thing ever yeah
it was it was like a revolutionary
invention now you got Texas everywhere I
feel like ding's position is getting a
little bit worse his greatest asset well
his greatest two assets the net on G6 is
totally restricted by the pawns and
number two right now nehal has a hanging
Pawn on H5 and maybe you might say well
you know what happens if you give this
Pawn away if you give this Pawn away
there's the danger of the queen dropping
back and then white pushing H5 and
shoving this Knight back toward h8 so
there is a ticking clock on the queen
side maybe something like Bishop C5 is
necessary but nihal's got to create some
counter play pretty quickly here maybe
Rook C4 yes he does there's a reason the
time was two minutes difference now it's
down to 30 seconds it's because it's
actually very difficult position to play
with black traditional Pawn break F6 is
oh oh I I actually think F6 might be
necessary and oh and to just take on E5
with
the night the night and Bishop takes Fe
Queen E5 and just sort of dynamic
counter play with like Bishop F6 or
something
yeah let's bring up an analysis word
real fast as nihal Ponders this very
committal move so what you're spelling
out I think is exactly what black should
go for F6 give up the pawn but in return
open up the center Arc the bishop on F6
and you have quite a few assets here in
return for the pawn you've got the big
Center and with White's clock dwindling
this might be the kind of position nehal
has to try to aim for guess what F6 is
on the board
this reminds me exactly of the of the
game from there this actually reminds me
literally like
move for move position for position of
their first game in the cgc matchup I
swear nehal was worse and was down a
pawn but created counter play and he had
a bishop versus knight situation like
maybe he was Knight versus Bishop but
very soon remember that and is Apon like
Queen in the end he he sucked upon for
counter play and it's we're almost
getting a Deja Vu moment and you know
those thoughts exist in players heads
like dude nihal does not go away I mean
I've got to put him like six feet below
the ground for the game to actually be
over he's gonna keep coming at me
because you have six looks great I
actually really like Black's position
and Anish Gary can second that thought
of course those of you who didn't see
Niall's first match against a niche do
yourself a favor and watch a recording
of that match after this one that was
something else Andy Hall had so many of
his vintage ridiculous comebacks in that
match as well wouldn't be a nehal match
without at least you know four or five
comebacks from a minus eight position
but he's actually taking a long think
here Lobby Bishop F6 looks automatic but
maybe he's attracted to the idea of
pressuring the F2 Pawn or playing a move
like Rook F5 he thinks this is an
important moment to play accurately in
but he ultimately goes for Bishop F6 and
E5 okay I think he was thinking more
about the move after Bishop F6 maybe
because you know you know people do that
and E4 so using the pawn as kind of an
anchor and preventing a white snipe from
getting back into the game although
Big Move yeah Knight G2 I mean I oh
you know what's funny I would trust
nihal on both sides
the black side of this and the white
side of this
now the moment he loses one of these
pawns he's in big big trouble so
ding is trying to get his Knight around
to F4 but Rook D6 a good prophylactic
move Knight F4 there might be Bishop
takes H4 and Niha wants to get this down
to a Time scramble ASAP
yes he does by the way ding's in a hotel
or something looks like it right obscure
painting on the wall I think he is
yeah I was gonna ask what you thought
but it does give me hotel Vibes for sure
that's interesting where though I mean
is he just sort of like making his way
to
is he playing in the world rapid and
Blitz
I think he might be but I would imagine
it's too early to find to Kazakhstan
like two weeks early for a three-day
tournament I don't know that F4 is on
the board now he's threatening Levy
Knight takes D5 and then Queen to C4
nehal has to address that thread maybe
Rook F7 is what the doctor ordered here
yes the ayokin's gun directly behind the
pawn that's exactly what he wanted seven
Rook D7 exactly 30 seconds now for nihal
yes but that's okay it's like the the
lower his time gets the stronger he gets
you know
precisely and it's not exciting until
until he gets down to two seconds uh
isn't there 1900
I think Rook D5 and queen C4 so so that
you can play Rook D1 in the end
ah Knight D5 is such a natural move but
Rook D5 yeah oops oops oops oops yeah
isn't missing that maybe that wasn't
even the best option but Rook e to E5 is
what niho was banking on forgetting that
the other Rook could come out to D1 he
might be losing here yeah I think he and
I both missed Rook D5 even though you
literally said Rook D5 I mean it's
he should have listened to you I mean
what can I say
I know doesn't doesn't know who the wise
guys are here five seconds for Newhall
can he pull out whoa
I mean C7 now hunger screen
ding could actually go Queen B3 here but
then there's the move A4 distracting the
queen so you've got to go for this
position yeah he didn't counter play he
didn't lose his Queen he sacrificed it
to get the two Rooks but rookie eight
Queen and E3 is a big threat
so Queen C4
Queen C4 Queen F7 maybe gotta keep
attacking the Rooks a night at fate
Knight f8
okay but where to from there King h e
ding might panic and start repeating
moves here oh my goodness this is
unbelievable ten seconds where's the win
is it Knight F4 is it a slow move
probably not at four whoa oh five it
should be seven no it's made in two
queen queen G8 yeah G8 Queen h8 yes
what if Bishop E7 there was Queen F5
yes yes oh amazing yeah what a game by
ding that was a great game excellent
game
and what composure and time pressure
this is what I mentioned in the pre-show
yes he loses a lot of games on time but
that doesn't mean he can't handle
himself well in time pressure and this
is exactly how nehal started his match
against Anish Geary so it's already
danger time
and nihal responds with a very creative
anti-sicilian here
yeah uh dingly Wren has just played a
Sicilian Defense which is also super
rare for him I mean he goes E4 E5 all
the way he is experimenting with
all sorts of openings this is this is
awesome I mean I I love this people
don't realize that dingley ran with the
black pieces is E4 E5 automatic to see
him holding like these imbalance
positions and kind of adjust his playing
style is super interesting yeah I'm
sorry I said it as if it was normal like
I didn't even bat an eye and then as you
started to talk I was like wait a second
when is the last time ding like didn't
play either a Berlin or a marshall like
what is he doing are we sure this is the
same guy yeah okay but
careful now because this is a very
dangerous line for black there's a rook
sacrifice here Levy I think that I've
fallen for before
and it goes something like CD Queen D4
Knight C6 which is very natural and then
after Knight C6 Queen C6 there's some
move there like Bishop F4 you just leave
The Rook on H1 in the corner I think
we're about to see something very
similar
oh yeah and here there we go there there
it is
I've fallen for this multiple times in
Blitz Games and after Queen H1 let me
show this on the analysis report
black loses I think on the spot castles
Bishop D7 and now just Bishop takes F6
and white gets a raging attack in return
for the exchange oh my gosh oh what a
yeah yeah rotate wow amazing you can
tell from ding's expression his mouth
opened half a millimeter more
exactly and that is how you knew by the
way I like how every move is made there
Queen B4 Queen C5 Queen decision oh my
God poison just any move what a
beautiful mating construction Queen
before so this line I mean if you take
the Rook on each one you lose if you
don't take the Rook on H1 if you play a
developing move like Bishop F5 white
just ignores and castles and you can't
get your Rook to d8 in time this is Mega
danger or Ding and he senses it yes okay
let's go back to the live position
wow that's uh
let me tell you something right now
if you don't know what you're getting
yourself into and you play Queen C6 and
your opponent plays Bishop G5 do you
know how dumb you feel like you feel
terrible because you're like you do feel
terrible because you're just like this
dude is just giving me a rook
but it doesn't work which means now you
start thinking am I already worse even
though you might not be but just
psychologically right Bishop G4 which
looks like it hangs a piece by the way
it doesn't wow
Bishop takes F6 is going to happen I
mean nehal has no choice the point of
Bishop G4 is to prevent white from
putting a rook on D1 what is the
follow-up though Levy to Bishop takes F6
does you want to take on H1 there yeah
and then there's Queen G4 and you take
back on F6 or something that's insane
but there's Bishop takes G7 in that
position well I guess we're about to
find out
no he just takes back oh so he wants
queen takes G4 and then he wants queen
takes H1 but there's a check on A4 in
that position which is super nasty oh
and queen C6 Bishop B5 should be five
oh this is gorgeous wow
and I won't make the moves on the
analysis board because I don't see
anyhow going for anything else here he's
just double checking that's crazy like a
pendulum Queen takes Bishop Queen out to
A4 it's crazy that Ding blundered
immediately after getting hit with
Bishop G5 that's life you know that's
just you get hit with a move like that
you're like oh my God you spend two
minutes
boom
fatal error I mean navigating navigating
your way through this position in a
Blitz game in a classical game it would
be difficult now nihal is taking
uh a good deal of time here there's just
nothing else he can do like once you're
you know ahead head first diving into
the water you gotta go Queen takes G4
and Sack that Rook
um doing evidently a bit chilly throwing
on a jacket we've had multiple players
with jackets and doors like they were
Chad was talking about Wesley yesterday
in his house or wherever he was he was
cold it's getting chilly I'll have to
see it bundling up I mean I'm in a
hoodie
yeah no same I I prefer commentating in
like warm clothes
yeah you know what they say I I I'm
sorry I know we have to focus on the
chest but now listen I know and it
doesn't seem like he's you know close at
all to making a move he's not going to
make one telepathically while his hands
are in his head uh they say that if you
have like ADHD or if you just like you
know your thoughts constantly bouncing
all over the place that wearing a hoodie
or a hat actually helps so sometimes
when I sit here and I need to get work
done I throw on a hoodie or my beanie
and it kind of like contains my head
like I just I feel more focused it's
kind of interesting so there you go I'm
not a doctor and not a physician helps
it helps me yeah yeah interesting not
all this time all this time I thought I
was getting advice from a qualified
individual now he castles first he
doesn't find Queen A4 check oh wow and
this allows ding now he's not out of the
woods but he can bring his Queen back to
C6 and he's stable here wow big mistake
there for nehal he just he didn't see a
check it happens it's still incredibly
dangerous don't get me wrong incredibly
dangerous
but the missing queen A4 check
wasn't Queen A4 was like almost winning
on the spot now I don't even know what
black would have played
King d8 it is it is a strange oversight
because Queen C6 Bishop B5 is pretty
easy to see and we might show this after
the game but for now they've got this
position ding is far from out of the
woods let me repeat that I mean look at
his King
yeah ding can't move anything like
Bishop H6 check King B1 or even F4 looks
very nice for white
um Bishop coming to G2 you X-ray the
queen am I missing why black is not
playing Rook to C8 is there like an
obvious
this is c a oh my God there's some crazy
tactics there Bishop C4 Maybe
oh DC4 Knight F6 yes
this is a Rebecca Harris type of
position wow yeah I was thinking like
you know C3 just prevent made but Bishop
C4 is just absurd no but Bishop C4
there's Bishop H6 check clearing the f8
square let me show this line actually
Rook C8 is a totally viable suggestion
and I was proposing Bishop C4 with the
idea of Knight takes F6 Jack and queen
E7 but but as usual with my ideas
there's a flaw and the flaws that black
can throw in this check and if you go
down the same line the black king has an
escape score on f8 I like Rook C8 I
think it's a good practical move
yeah sort of surprised he hasn't played
it faster but he's gone Rook to d8 okay
what's his follow-up gonna be
that's also logical in C8 oh my gosh
you want to hear something ridiculous
what the best move is F4 and the second
best move is King B1 you just leave your
queen on G4 like a normal person would
ah Queen C8 actually threatens nothing
because you can't take White's Queen
because of Knight C7 it's amazing
ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous and the point
about four of course is to take the
sting out of the move Bishop H6 Levy
Bishop H6 is actually the threat yes and
then you're gonna lose your queen yes so
that's why both moves they're not waste
moves they're actually improving my
position I I think as a human I would
probably play King B1 here I don't I
don't know the difference I just don't
like that my king is still in C1 after
F4 but uh I mean they're both very
logical and you know there's a man on
Earth that would play King and he's
played it yeah
he's done it
I think ding is suppressing a smile I
think he like you know it's a
competitive match but sometimes you're
like what the
like like really like this guy just went
King C want to be one of the hanging
Queen on G4 now Bishop H takes your Levy
I think would be my choice for black get
your king a square otherwise yeah you're
not gonna survive this with 23 seconds
and E6 apparently not the move uh Queen
before Queen H4 and queen H4 talk about
a pendulum swing yes he finds this King
G7 Queen G5 is Checkmate Queen G5 is
made oh my God this is just this is
ridiculous and Rook takes the eight on
the next move is when I'm surprised it's
not more than plus three
yeah where's the king Go I mean it's
just for Zions wow
unreal
uh what we come back strike by nihal we
called it by the way like I mean when
you get hit with a move like King B1
it's over I mean you yeah
psychologically cannot bounce back two
times in that game uh ding got hit with
moves that just blew his mind Bishop G5
and King B1 I mean you can only recover
so many times from getting just struck
and knocked down in a fight and uh that
happened twice in that match and in that
game and we're all level so it seems
like the players are going to be beating
each other up with the white pieces
that's sort of right now the storyline
yeah this is an incredibly tactical
start to the match I did not anticipate
two of these positions in a ding nehal
match because nihal he likes the London
ding likes one D4 and the Catalan both
of them are playing E4 and going at each
other's throats are you kidding me this
is awesome and they're repeating the
exact same opening from game one so that
begs the question Levy where is nihal's
Improvement
nihal might just think he got a
completely normal position and then
George right that's true that could be
that could be it he could say I was fine
after F6 you know what I mean
and uh which is a risky approach though
because the the path is very narrow and
I didn't like his position from a
practical standpoint his pawns were weak
you don't want to get those types of
positions in a Blitz game where the
margin of error is just like totally
non-existent and by the way we have
breaking news that the uh pregame
prediction of 50 50 uh is still 50 50.
thank you for bringing that up on the
screen
um it's a very informative graphic yes
just kidding please please don't fire me
from this position
um by the way it says 50 50 but it was
51.49 no I mean our graphic literally
said 51.49 but now it says 50 50. I mean
this is the closest match I think we've
ever had literally ever yeah smarter
chess needs to be just careful about
these drastic changes I mean come on you
know from 49 to 50 you need to take a
chill pill man I know so I I really
wonder if you ran the simulation between
these two players 10 000 times what
would happen I do like what I want to
Echo your point dingly Ren is a
strategic grinding positional style
player with black and with white nihal
sarin same thing like simple openings
pragmatic slowly building up his
position and improving it and a very
good Defender
um
what is going on today these guys are
playing barn burner chess like there is
just no no sense of safety I mean
they're just throwing kicks and punches
right like it's
it's a weird match crazy they're totally
shape-shifting today I mean if if I just
saw the game scores without
knowing who was playing I don't know
which match I would predict this to be I
mean maybe Hikaru against paravian uh
maybe aronian undraken but definitely
not ding against nihal but I mean this
in the most positive way imaginable yeah
mvl Neville maybe mvl netpo for sure
like super Scrappy yeah so nihal this
time does not Castle so quickly
um instead of opting I guess for for
Queen D7 and that's simple move yeah
yeah yeah it covers covers the queen
side I mean black has to castle at some
point his position is like if black was
not allowed to Castle black would be
lost so
um maybe uh yeah maybe Blackwell Castle
maybe black will just play F6 King F7
actually
that is an epic Fork right there Queen
D3 working A6 and G6 how many times has
that phrase been said uh Rook on A6 and
a knight on G6 yeah so yeah this is what
you kind of have to Castle
um so you're right now the question that
Ding is is posing himself here is how
how do I prepare for black castling like
how do I set myself up in order to
attack H5 and I like Rook C1 that's a
pretty low stakes low risk move
and it seems to be time for nehal to
Castle because if you delay too many
moves Levy I mean queen C2 Queen C8 you
could get stuck in the center forever
yeah you could
wow
this is uh
there we go yeah this is not easy this
is not easy
okay so what now for ding because the
pawn 95 is a weakness it's not easy to
move this Knight away it's not easy to
protect this Pawn a second time so maybe
bishop D4 but that takes away the
rightful Square from the Knight which is
a common problem
uh when you've got multiple minor pieces
vying for and jostling for the same
square
yep trying to find what the plan will be
for nehal if not for F6
and I can't really find one
I don't exactly know yeah A4 but same
question for white like what is a good
healthy waiting move set my waiting move
for white
A3 rookie one yeah but they said you
play A4
yeah that's true
I can go Rook B8 I can play on the queen
side I mean black has finally moved away
from the center so yes white has the
pawn majority but you can kind of play
this benko style Rook B8 meet B3 with A4
and the pressure can be a little bit
unpleasant here
it could be yeah and if uh if ding puts
all his
eggs in the basket of winning the H5
pawn it actually could backfire because
you win the H5 pawn and then realize
your entire Queen side disintegrated so
Bishop D4 played this time
I like this move and again F6 still
Queen D3 even though you've castled you
haven't taken the sting out of the fork
no I mean that yeah that pawn on H5
looks just destined to perish for the
greater good of the black position it
feels like I mean
logically this position doesn't make any
sense like the Knight on G6 can't move
the pawn and H5 can't move I mean you
have a rook in A6 and yet black is fine
black is fine objectively but there is
this big threat of just Knight to E1
labian what I pointed out in the first
game in which they reached this position
once the h-bond disappears if white can
keep the e-pawn alive you mentioned the
word disintegrates Black's kingside can
disintegrate in a matter of like three
moves
yes I mean if anything that the Knight
can just go right back to G5 it's true
exactly
yeah there is a world we live in where
only the queen is on H5 for white and
like the pieces never get to follow up
and nothing happens but that's kind of
unlikely
apparently the top move is just Rook f8
to C8 and that is not an easy move to
play because white can respond by taking
and moving the Knight away and black is
just in time says the computer to create
Queen side counter play and he all does
something very similar Rook to C6
fighting for control of the only open
file always an important thing to do
yes that Rook was destined to get off of
A6
so Queen A4 is a move but then black
just doubles on the C file
I guess that would be great
I mean you lose the pawn on A5 I don't
know
if nihal is able to trade queens and
Rooks though he is super happy I mean
so without question
even by the way no Queens on the board I
mean I already like Black's position
more
I mean I I would go so far say even if
you lose the h-pawn it
even if you do that and then manage to
trade Queens I still think black gets
full compensation with this major Pawn
on T5 which you cannot fall asleep on in
the context of an end game it's a
protected passer yes and the the closer
we get to that end game the bigger of an
asset it becomes
um
right now
he is thinking
is dingly run
yeah why is he not playing Queen A4
well I guess Rook takes C6 Queen takes
E6 Knight to E1 comes to mind
and then I guess you can play a move
like Queen C4 to tie white down let's do
this bishop and that's a very fragile
construction because the bishop defends
a very important Pawn
B3 though I saw
E3
what do you mean B3 B3 yeah
Billy three
I don't know I I I'm confused you
suggested a plant like sometimes we
suggest plans and we sit here and we're
just like we don't realize what's bad
about it
yeah you're not playing it they don't
play it oh no now they do following Our
advice Levy wow look at that
91 yeah he's rerouting he wants to take
on H5
yeah so Queen C4 B3 I agree that looks
very dubious for black because then if
you play Queen B4 the Knight can jump
into C2 and finally protect the bishop
so the queen is free to roam about the
cabin
you take on H5 you come back and then
you move your H Pawn to H5 and uh black
snide goes
boom boom I want to talk about going
back to h8
um what's the move for black here
great question I mean it's probably just
a sacked upon and go Queen to A4 and hit
the bishop hit the A2 pawn and you all
does something very similar oh what's so
important Levy is that Queen G4 there
there was Knight takes E5 yes yes
infiltrating White's position preparing
Rook to C4
so nehal just banking on the activity of
his pieces I think ding overlooked the
idea of Queen D3 I mean I think like
naturally you you think my opponent is
going to take on A2 right he attacked my
Pawn now says I don't need your stupid
Pawn what I needed for you what I need
is for you to run out of moves
and that's why we're here now
another detail Queen E4 was possible
there but no he sticks to Rook C4 is
there and if you play A Tribe Knight
takes E5
so ridiculous and B3 same idea b395
oh my gosh Knight takes E5 hits the
queen and after Knight takes E5 Queen
takes D4 the White Queen is hanging so
you can't take the Rook
five seconds for ding is he losing
control here he does play H5 uh yeah I
think so I think oh my God don't play
Queen takes D4 because there was Queen
takes and Knight C6
so nehal takes correctly okay so now we
have an end game
who's better and why probably black at
this point probably black how was the
black Rook not trapped though Rook D4 I
guess just always and even Rook G5 in
some positions
but you don't want to go Rook C4 because
then white takes and jumps into E5 and
you lose the C4 Pawn that is so that is
correct you've got to kind of eat it
here and allow white white truck to
infiltrate
Bishop D6 to threaten Bishop G3
what a tactic and he missed it oh a
knee-hole's not gonna miss that oh no we
gotta move ding started to give up all
his pawns now he's losing yeah he's
losing unreal
oh nihal's coming back for more it's
over it's over wow Bishop D6 Bishop G3
amazing
but I'm even more impressed Levy with
the way he handled that middle game
Queen D3 Rook C4 Rook takes D4 how many
potential blunders could he have made in
that position no navigated that like
Magnus Carlson yeah I mean maybe even
better like Queen C4 Queen D3 was just
just unreal I mean foregoing the free
porn yeah and by the way the problem A2
survived the whole end game the problem
is all the other pawns died
and you would think you know given that
the pawn on H5 disappeared that that was
the X Factor of white one h5p would be
better nihal found a way to sacrifice
that pawn to have his cake and eat it
too incredible
just precision and technique in that end
game that was Sublime and and now he
gets a massive confidence boost he went
back to the opening that he lost in uh
in game one but this is a common mistake
a lot of it you know even very strong
Club players up until 2000 make us make
this mistake saying you know they're
lost in an opening he didn't lose game
one due to the opening at all he lost
game one because it was a you know it
was a complex decision in the 20th movie
opening actually was not bad and so he
repeats the same opening now he wins
it's a super boost of confidence and um
he's now one with both colors in this
match
he has indeed and ding reverts back to
what he's most familiar with which I
think is a good strategy when you're
facing an early deficit we have a real
Lopez now what you saw there earlier
Levy was the bishop coming to D2 and
then moving back to C1 and the reason
nehal did that is because black put his
Bishop on the h5d1 diagonal and in the
Rue Lopez it's very frequently
considered that a bishop on this
diagonal is misplaced because the Knight
can hit it with Tempo and drive it back
to a very passive Square
it's interesting that
um
ding experimented one time
and now we're back to these e45
structures the ding was like ah let's
see what he's got in the Sicilian oh
maybe not maybe oh okay yeah it was good
while it lasted
that's kind of
now we're going to be playing these
super complex uh spanishes probably for
the duration of the match because I
didn't realize it's not worth battling
In the Sicilian Defense uh it's better
than a Berlin
it is yes as we see D5 there and four
pawns along the uh the fourth rank
and hitting so now a big question do you
I don't think you take on F3 because
then white goes with Knight F5 and that
initiative Levy unfolds really quickly I
think you actually go Bishop G6 not
because the bishop is so good but
because it actually defends the F5
Square
yes
that's the important thing the Knight
was looking to get into a five I mean
we're gonna see Knight H4
what's the idea here we're gonna see
Knight H4 then maybe Knight takes E4 no
that doesn't work because E7 hangs with
check
so how how much of a fiend is nihal
sarin for that F5 Square
yeah I mean your play does frequently
revolve around that square in these
positions what about e takes D5 and
hunting for the E5 Pawn is that an angle
worth exploring
looks like very typical martial style
compensation
I feel like there's
a complicated
if you don't take on D5 by the way what
is okay oh please please Knight H4 he
goes for your initial idea sounds like
if we could bring him I was gonna say he
is indeed a fiend let's bring up that
analysis board
just to show people might take C4 you
could get very excited about this oh D
for Bishop H4 common idea but after
Knight takes G6 if you take back on G6
you lose E4 if you take on G3 Knight
takes E7 is a check so all of this would
fall apart with Black's King on h8 with
a king on G8 count up the minor pieces
and white is a piece ahead so ding
taking a fundamentally different
approach and pushing D4
big big committal decision but you often
see black engineering the pawn cube with
D4 and C4 in these types of positions
that is very sharp
that is very very sharp
for black to play the move C5 C4 here
and try to just completely break down
the white position of the white position
is super resilient
good reinforcement yep H4 like what is
the plan here
Bishop G5 but now rookie six and zillion
like black is also very fundamentally
sound here but I like H4
I think we're going after it if you're
white
what about Queen F3 to prevent H6
I don't know
hard to find a move here for both sides
I know I mean visually visually White's
position looks great but
okay so which way is black going to
recapture CD has the drawback of
allowing Rook ac1 but maybe that favors
black he plays Edie whoa
I really want to play F4
F4 move my Knight Knight takes G7 F5
something like that I mean just in the
four E5 or E5
but F4 is their H6
gosh that's so crazy
Bishop H4 Queen takes F4
that position should come with an
complementary Advil
Rook F1 yeah wow
kind of keeps the tension
Rook T1 is a ridiculous move I mean it
looks like it's legitimately you have no
idea how to play chess and I the point
is that you're just you're preventing C4
that's what you're doing and
you're if if your d-pawn moves out of
the way yeah you pressure D4 I mean it
actually is incredibly logical just
visually it looks like you have no idea
how to play chess because like what is
your Rook doing on D1 behind your D Pawn
yeah you can conclude one of two things
for mercury one either it's a beginner
or it's like a 2650 GM other other
players don't put Rooks on closed files
I mean it's yeah it looks and like what
now white is going to play Bishop D2
ship C1 I mean just set it up for the
next game
yeah you might have but you're probably
right you're probably right because at
least Bishop D2 puts some pressure on
the Knight and you know strains Black's
Queen a little bit
yeah I was thinking Bishop D2 maybe
black would just play Knight C6 and now
your Bishop looks stupid on D2 but I
he Hall agrees all right well the bishop
dies uh this looks a bit optimistic
though I mean it just doesn't how do you
break in is just F4 E5 All In
I think yeah next move has to be up for
especially if black plays Knight C6
aiming for E5 white is in time to play
F4 but how is white going to involve
this God of a light scored Bishop I
don't think you can really break through
without it
yeah I uh
I was going to say that there's a piece
in the white position that's pretending
to be a bishop but it's actually a pawn
and I think I think this Chad can
identify it uh that does not look like a
bishop it might be a bishop again if it
aims if it sits on B3 that was the
drawback of Knight C6 thing better have
a a good follow-up in mind here maybe C4
but I thought Knight before in C4 yeah
or C4 first oh that looks dangerous for
white
but E5 is so sharp
yeah and you pointed out ideas of like
Knight takes H6 and F5 is there like E5
H5 Queen G5 oh my gosh
I think that was the that was the queen
nut traps
yeah it sort of is I mean it has H4 and
it has G5
so the good thing about nehal's position
is that it's easier to play he knows
what his next move is ding is the one
who has to calculate the heck out of C4
which I think he's gonna play for the
record I think he's gonna go C4
yeah work I am man it's so tough to
decide like do you want the white Bishop
to get out of there completely like
night before First bishop B1 maybe you
don't even have to play C4
yeah but you would include this night
before move but then A3 Bishop A2 and
um black might be losing straight up and
maybe you want your knight for just
general defensive purposes you want to
bring it back to E7 as we're talking
ding is thinking he's down to a minute
and this is exactly what niho wants he
wants this game to turn into a Time
scramble
a bullet game like this with a king side
attack just always favors white I feel
like just much easier to play moves
ding has sunk right about a minute on
this moment he better come up with
something good he's down to 45 seconds
yes it's too much she has to trust his
gut here all right I'm getting stressed
40 seconds now
this is too little this is too little
because here's the problem I don't think
he can even anticipate White's next move
unless he does something very forcing
right if he plays a slow move he's
leaving himself no time to react to a
move he will not expect this is nuts he
has 20 seconds on the clock 20 seconds
he's still not moving I hope his
internet is working it looks like it is
I think he's just deep in thought trying
to figure out C4 but he's missing the
forest for the trees 14 seconds now on
the clock you've got to make a move ding
wait this is crazy 10 seconds
and he finally plays Queen C8 preventing
Levy the movie five which I think is a
great move that E5 there's Rook takes F5
that literally I think was the top
computer move because the insane is
exactly the same but he he has 10
seconds on the clock I mean what's he
done here
and if I'm knee-hal I'm considering
making a quick move like Bishop B3 but
then black has Knight to eight three
forcing the bishop out so why not A3
Bishop B1 Bishop A2 something like that
try to keep the tension if your
knee-hole
Queen H4 is also possible to threaten
Knight takes H6 one move threats can be
very effective and your opponent has 10
seconds in a middle game
yeah I think I would just play A3 here I
mean I don't know maybe I'm completely
naive or maybe I'm missing something but
no no A3 is a great move in the
opponent's time pressure
yeah but but you know nihal is like ah
he's got 10 seconds I also will get 10
seconds in many ways getting in a
scramble is even more stressful than
playing 10 versus 40. you know what I
mean like at least Center yourself but
in a scramble you can never
then kind of procrastinates on Knight A5
now your move A3 is possible to make
some Luft for the bishop one very
important detail of is that Bishop D5
you always have to watch for Rook takes
D5 and the Knight loses its support 14
seconds now for knee-hole Here We Go
folks
this is it our first official time
scramble of the match seven seconds each
that was threatening Knight takes H6
forces ding to make a big concession and
give up that Bishop I don't like this no
right back to G3 maybe whoa
G4 watch your queen though King H2
Bishop D5 H1 yep and E5 was being
prepared wow Surgical and A5 chasing the
bishop away and carving out the D5
Square oh he's rerouting to E4 now uh oh
and then F5 is going to be really
dangerous
he might play it now
he goes 904 first oh grabbing a bunch of
Pawns C4 Maybe
he's gotta move he had literally point
three seconds Queen out of six seconds
six I'd have 64.
oh my God died of six wins the queen
oh my goodness
oh my gosh yeah we never see that that
must be an internet issue
we literally never see nehal flag in
this kind of situation ever
oh my gosh when's the last time lost the
game on time
I and not just that in a position where
he can win the queen in one move let me
bring up that final position for those
who want a refresher on why we're so
crazed at what just happened
all nihal had to do was Knight E4 to F6
check Levy and the queen disappears
you'll find this while skydiving and
having two seconds on his clock I swear
he hit ding with the exact same tactic
in this comeback game the last time he
had the white pieces it was like a
knight discovered attack
and queen F3 was such a genius move
because he would have played that move
anyway in response to Queen D7 this is
still winning
anyways
yeah amazing yeah I I realized he had
this idea to Anchor in the Knight on F6
and sacrifice it just unbelievable wow
yeah we just never see this we're so
used to Excellence and Perfection from
the hall and time scrambles we got
Perfection again Levy to reach that
point and maybe he had a hard time
dragging his Mouse to have sex I mean
your hands are shaking in these
situations even if you're knee-haw oh
yeah they they really are I mean
it is it is a stressful experience E4 by
the way this
this position is breaking all the
principles of Chess just both sides
overextending hyper aggressive making
multiple moves with pieces in the
opening
um that's what you get when you play
over goes on sometimes
I played these positions with black and
never enjoyed them I just feel like I'm
getting checkmated whichever side of the
board I go to and black literally in
these lines can go kingside then stay in
the center or can go Queen side
so this just seems practically very
unpleasant but from a positional
standpoint you know you could argue that
you have the bishop pair and White's got
this isolated Pawn
yeah I uh I have to sneeze and I think
it's because I'm allergic to positions
that look like this yeah long castles I
mean visually I I agree uh it looks like
a disaster for black but
I mean that's why the best players in
the world
no but I think the hall has done
something wrong here if he goes F5 I
think some people may be wondering why
not F5 at the very least there is G4
breaking up the pawn chain
and all you've done is create more
weaknesses on the king's side I feel
like F5 is a deranged move yeah it is
um
Knight F6 what like D5 yeah you got a
castle probably right
and it's important that the queen
defense G5 no wait a minute dude
Castle's F4 how was black not just lost
I don't know hey I think Buck is lost
like I'm I'm no staunch defender of this
position in the black side and he all
just keeping his King she's like I'm
gonna chill in the center for the time
being
F4 I mean but you you do run the risk
like if black plays three moves and
consolidates White's just permanently
worse in every end game so
uh I love F4 by the way I think that's
the move
yeah for D5 F4 looks pretty natural
D5 immediately I guess black can take
and Tuck the king away on f8 if
necessary and maybe opening up the C
file is actually counterproductive
huh
I don't know killing a project if you
say
yes there we go ding as usual just
taking 40 seconds and coming up with an
engine move
yeah what does Mike do
like what is the move here
that wasn't my responsibility my
responsibility was to suggest the move
for the site that I prefer playing I
don't prefer this wasn't part of our
deal yeah so I abstain you know
um I don't know man I don't know what
black plays I mean I was thinking like
Bishop E6 or something
I was briefly considering Bishop takes
D4 and yes I know I'm a psycho
but the actual reason it doesn't work I
think is just the simple Queen to D2
and we will not talk about that line any
further
also I feel like Queen E2 probably just
some direct line of assault
yeah Queen fill in the blank is just
crushing
no I mean it is a free Pawn make no
mistake if anybody's confused in the
shower we're not we're just not taking
it it's because uh
also isn't there Bishop D4 FG like oh
yeah the the rather straightforward F
takes G5 threatening Knight F6 check
yeah yeah do not I mean it is a free
Pawn
you know comes per two
what what hurts you here if you're black
is like Bishop he says there's always
this move Knight to C5 hitting B7 and
then preparing F5 White's position is
just pulsating with tactical energy
pulsating with tactical energy that's
a Legendary Legendary commentator call I
the reason hell is thinking it's really
hard to recover from flagging
when you're about to win a queen
so yeah no it's it's crazy the
psychological effect of that cannot be
understated
especially if you're someone who's so
not used to doing that
you know I was like what happened there
yeah I guess he just didn't get his move
up in seven minutes literally okay so we
have gfgf Bishop
full G4
G4 Knight D6 check
lots of candidate moves here I love G4
oh yes you're in a role tactically I
want to play G4 or queen E2 what's wrong
with queen is he gonna Castle
so I think we need to you will castle
kingside that's why I like G4 open up
the G file as an insurance policy
against black castling
whoa G4 there you go
I'm such a better chess player when it's
not my pieces
it's just like
yeah this is just like pure fun for
white and pure torture for black if I'm
new I'm considering Levy actually Bishop
takes E4 buy yourself some time yeah
yeah it looks like you don't want to but
if queening for just Queen E7 and maybe
Castle coincide
yes
Bishop E4 I I like it a lot I mean the
thing is what do you do if you play
Bishop H7 I'll play F5 I'll just play
like Alpha zero just wall off your
bishop and
yeah he takes yep
okay big decision actually for for ding
Knight takes E4 is unappealing
aesthetically but might actually be the
best move go to C5 prepare your idea at
five F6 later
oh and 94 Castle's King side there's the
move Knight E4 to G5 oh yep and that's
that's that's a you better find the
resign button fast That's All She Wrote
there yeah that's literally the end of
the game oh my God can I show a quick
line
Knight G5 so you can't take because of
mate if you play rookie eight and pave
the path to f8 Rook takes H6 yeah but
that's not the end of the story I just
wanted to show the idea of Rook to h a
check
forcing the bishop away to make contact
between the queen and the F7 Pawn that
ladies and gentlemen is checkmate
yeah Checkmate is an understatement that
is a beating that you just you just got
beat physically that's what that's what
happened but um well put well put
what is the thought here he may also
want to play Queen E4 and like
oh
you made a third move whoa rookie won
okay I can get behind that I mean you're
putting the Rook on an open file wow and
you're recapturing with the rook and hey
he almost took that pawn he just
snatched it out of White's grass so he's
able to get away with this just in case
anybody's confused last time there was a
rook on D1 pinning the bishop to the
queen right now that Rook is now
laterally hitting the bishop so if you
pin the bishop to the queen with the
queen that's different because the
bishop can actually move
right so in case the audience is
confused
um that's what you can actually take and
if ding doesn't win this game now is
just gonna be a thief he just wins the
pawn and runs home and
I don't know if 92 is the way to go but
let's see
I guess he's re-maneuvering the Knight
to F5 and Whitney Hall is saying is hey
my king is actually as safe as anywhere
on the board it's not safe at all but
comparatively the King on f8 isn't too
unhappy I am worried about nihal's clock
once again 30 seconds ding has an entire
minute extra
and he's just got long-term play like
ding doesn't need to hurry right he's
only a pawn down
oh you know what I wanted to play Rook
H5
oh that is a that is a lovely looking
move but the next Queen A2 is his idea
yeah I know but so maybe just King P1
yeah probably just King me one but I
keep wondering that's a big move
move though you just know it
yeah it's uh I don't know maybe you can
like trap the queen if it gets down to
it too but maybe not maybe not yeah
King B1
foreign
[Music]
Knight F5 looks great G5 looks great but
now you're getting down to that road
seconds by the way Rook D1 is a huge
threat
I was gonna say you're getting down to
that territory where you may have to
make a transition to an end game
or you could just Checkmate a guy Queen
C5 he's not gonna Black's not gonna make
it to an end game 97 check is next
oh my gosh there's gonna be some
nasty tactic here 97 and Bishop d3's
Queen F5 is just made oh my gosh Knight
C6 you can play a quick windmill
Windmill and then go back to E7 and I
would just win The Rook on h8
yeah just Knight yes yes or or just
Bishop B5 and keep the status quo
but I don't know about that
might let black off the hook wait Bishop
B5 Queen E4
yes oh that's a check I guess White's
probably still winning after King and
two but I agree yeah yeah you probably
are you probably have some 97 at least
you're not losing it's probably a draw
yeah Bishop oh my God Bishop takes B2
seriously
oh because Knight A4 Jesus what a
resource and guess what dings down to 24
seconds this game ain't over just yet
where is the win where is the win Knight
takes H6 check maybe I think it's Knight
takes H6 check yeah or not it apparently
wasn't
is it because of Queen E1 and the king
sidesteps the bishop
oh my God black could win this game
black could absolutely win this game oh
this is insane King B3 this is insane
Bishop C
two
White's still holding on what hurts
white is the lack of checks
in his position Bishop H7 Bishop F5
Bishop oh and he loses 200 is queen king
B4 is forced and then there's Bishop f8
but then Rook G two no now make a move
he's gonna
Flags into flag
gotta just make a move King B5 and
White's Out of the Woods oh can we just
quickly show that before we go to break
Bishop H7 Bishop F5 absolutely white by
the way buddy before I do queen E1 was a
very hard move to find this was the
winning move for black no Queen D6 and
now Bishop f8 pins the queen but you
called it a little bit earlier oh this
was after
when was this take to yeah and then and
then yeah right here wow Checker rooskis
can't can't go to f8 and Bishop F5 picks
up the queen on G4 a heartbreaker
followed by a heartbreaker as both sides
have now lost an absolute back-breaking
game that ends in a flag Levy what a
crazy sequence of events uh I got
nothing to say I got another say I think
everyone needs a break I think
commentary needs a break players need a
break Spectators need a break uh this is
everything we ever wanted and more I'm
so pumped what a match thus far what an
incredible match what a comeback just a
vintage knee-haw game folks we will give
the players a much deserved breather
you're watching the speed Chess
Championship an unmissable match
unfolding here between nihal sarin and
dingler and we will be back with the
second half of the five plus one portion
on the other side of this short break
foreign
[Music]
makes shows like this possible which is
why our twitch subscribers will never
see ads on chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we all know and love we see nihal sarin
on camera there what a match what a
match is unfolding here at the speed
Chess Championship round of 16. it's
been a pleasure covering the match
alongside I am Levy Rosman as we look at
nihal sarin's player card Levy we've
gotten all we can eat and then some yes
we have can't say it any better myself
he's got 3 200 average rating in Blitzen
bullet which is literally all you're
talking about I can't hear you just yet
speechless Championship uh uh you oh
like Don you can hear me I hope Chad can
hear me at least
um
yeah I mean listen you can't get any
better than 3300 um pragmatic playing
style has not been so pragmatic those
thus far we've had some unbelievable
knockout style games and we've also had
uh two flags back to back so three to
two after five this is just about the
closest that I can get this is what we
predicted uh smarter chess had this kind
of call and thus far looks like smarter
chances right
and and we just knew it right you could
just feel it it could feel it in the air
and both players have now suffered a
very painful defeat but now the ball is
in ding's court it's in his court
because he's losing by one but also
because he just played an extractable
game only to stumble at the end but all
credits anyhow the way he makes lemonade
out of lemons regardless of how losing
he is is just it's just uncanny it's
black magic and
ding has to put this behind him
I think both these guys are quite good
at putting losses like that behind them
um at least it it seems that way thus
far I mean
I don't think there is a better way to
come back from being flagged in a very
close game and one that you were a move
away from winning then to flag your
opponent in a game that you very much
could have been losing so a little bit
better than that so
um
yeah fascinating stuff thus far ding
kind of shakes his head there
interesting what is it
before the game even starts yeah you
haven't made any moves and
I'm a big fan of the opening choices in
this match I love to see nehal playing
E4 I personally think that that move
fits him very well
um he is a shapeshifter he can play any
style he wants a London grind it out end
game super tactical game he's
comfortable everywhere but just for the
sake of variety Levy and maybe I'll jinx
it and he'll play London but something
tells me we're gonna keep getting E4
yep oh I did Jinx him
wow
wow unbelievable Bishop F4 yeah no what
is a main line
okay I can get behind this
all right let me send me slav action
okay
never hurt anybody
E3 traditional
solid system
yep
who do you think is gonna win Brazil or
Croatia
I'm a big I like Croatia
Brazil just seems so inspired this year
I am rooting for Croatia for sure
what do we have Monster Squad anyway
neither of these players represent
either of those uh nations with a chip
on their shoulder ever since they lost
seven to one
to Germany it's too too soon Man Too
Soon Gotta Wait like five World Cups to
talk about that um this is like the most
flexible position of all time right like
it's like Rook 81 Rook F1
um E4
very yeah very normal plans
yeah E4 is is kind of derogori here now
you can start with Bishop D3
but you're playing E4 at some point
that's basically why it's only long-term
idea
yes
I mean I've played a few games here
where I try to Checkmate black on H7 it
doesn't always work
you go like Knight G5
yeah E4 put my queen on H4 after the big
trade Bishop D3
and great so on and so forth in the game
yeah this one now this one is slowing
down in Pace I feel like
yeah I feel like the player is kind of
just taking a breather I think it's
worth showing why E4 can backfire
sometimes if we can pull up an analysis
board the problem is that black
basically takes everything and you would
like to play C5 you can't do that yet
but what you can do is Chase the queen
away first and once black plays C5 his
bishops come out and I've had games
where I just end up being worse in a
position like this Black's aiming at f2
the queen can be misplaced so you got to
be very careful about when you play E4
that's the moral of the story here
whoa yeah you know taking
big decision there
what
I don't know about that after Ed
yeah let's just think better
normally he is like if you have to play
CD in these positions okay ding what
playing CD which is solid I guess he's
just saying he's totally fine here as
well but after Ed I thought he was
slightly better
yeah that's very interesting I I don't
realize why he played C takes D5
um
A6 prevents Knight B5 naturally
so I play A4 in some of these positions
or white
yeah yeah prevent B5
FIFA prevent B5 maybe play A5 yourself
maybe some Bishop going to A3
yeah this is the first sterile position
we've had all match I think that's why
we're feeling so dejected we've got a
little too used to Tactical fireworks
I know we have a totally symmetrical
position this one is going to take like
10-12 minutes this might be the first
draw of the match too
how boring it's gonna be the last game
of the match the way it's going I mean
of the segment
I know I can just play this position for
30 minutes Chad how you guys how you
guys doing
you guys doing all right yeah this is a
good time to check in mental health
check yeah
all of Chet needs a therapy session
complimentary therapy sessions for the
first hundred Chatters or something
um
E5 maybe your move A4 that comment is
aging pretty well I think nihal is
ultimately trying to get his Knight
around to D3
but okay you can get traded yeah
I don't know who nihal thinks he's
fooling playing Mainline Queen spawn
openings
uh against the London guy or he should
play the English or he should play E4
you know
that's yeah I mean I I guess he's just
trying to take a deep breath kind of
play one of these solid games the issue
is you can slip into a worse position if
you're white like black can go Knight E4
and if I had to choose the side I think
black is doing smidge more comfortable
here
I agree I think the bishop on B7 is
a comfortable anchor and I think White's
Queen side Knight is sort of misplaced
it's like very difficult to find a home
for it you could play Knight F4 and
yep Bishop back Knight D3 and so on
the hell is very thirsty this game also
oh yeah I haven't been looking at the
player cameras he drinking a lot of
water yeah I was gonna say um
this is the fascinating chess Insight
that you have to bring to the commentary
table when both guys are taking a minute
per move
um and the position has like very little
life in it the plans are sort of obvious
so
you know what okay Queen B1 Queens
getting out of the way the action maybe
gonna go to the corner then 95.
ooh spicy I think 95 is likely there's
also this incredibly cumbersome idea of
Rook C2 Knight back to C1 Bishop back to
F1 and finally you can put your knight
on D3 but it's like you do all of this
to play Knight T3 and then you have
nowhere to go from there
yep
so Rook C8 I would suggest
a revolutionary idea of occupying an
open file for black
also
H5 all right
I don't know about that move Knight
chief
it's the equivalent of throwing paint on
those uh on uh or like throwing like uh
like some orange weird substances on
those paintings and museums you know we
were just like very unstable everything
was good yeah everyone showed up and
just vandalized the painting
and you know
uh I could could work I don't know G5
next by black H4 by black maybe maybe
but concretely I was worried about
Knight G3 okay niho goes Knight to E5
yeah and just splatter some egg white on
White's King side with h4h3 ding is very
tactically his mindset here is
aggressive Queen G5 he wants to check
May white on the king side
yeah ding kind of sensed that nothing
was going on so he said okay maybe I'll
make something happen I mean a big win
here with black relatively low risk
there's a crazy threat of Bishop takes
E5 and Knight D2 to F3 check but
U-Haul chases him away it's a moot point
very committal though positionally the
move F4
extremely committal right and he could
blow the center up later with F6 E5 or
the other Knight will go to G4 and
and black will be like completely like
winning basically
but I think H5 has already been a
success
okay well
just play H5 in any position and
hope for the best
good chance he'll win that's that's
basically what players do now it's a
page five like as early as move three
and it just produces the right kind of
effect on your opponent nihal again look
at the clock down to 40 seconds we've
had one player doing this every game
mm-hmm Bishop takes and I think it's
just going from bad to worse he's now
given up the better Bishop that he had
and the light squares in the center
yeah but you know this is the phase of
the game where nihal activates
yeah he wakes up down 20 seconds just
two minutes on the clock faster yeah yep
Knight C6 maybe eliminate the light
score Bishop but
okay first he plays Knight G3
might as well
who needs that E4 Pawn
now Knight C6 I think
yeah
I was saying maybe you can sacrifice it
but yeah Knight C6 is nice
and this is somehow where nihal is just
unbeatable
yep
and it's actually hard to defend the E4
Pawn if you think about it after it
takes takes white will double on the C
file and you can't really afford to lose
this Pawn so ding will have to find some
tactical solution here but I don't see
anything off the top of my head
what if he just plays Queen D7
here
yeah and just sucks The Rook you can't
take on e4 black sex movies H4
well definitely an idea worth exploring
he decides to not lose any material for
37 Queen D5 maybe he does go Queen B7 oh
now the Rogue watch is the queen
yep now the Pawn's not hanging
by the way was there Bishop D2
oh
anyway
uh-huh oh defending E3 yeah good point
okay ding
but since 995 and he all triples but he
doesn't have access to the C7 Square so
the C file isn't as impressive as it may
appear but how does ding make progress
here
yeah why can't they all just go F5 G5
you mean ding like
uh yeah sorry nehal cannot move things
pieces yes
[Laughter]
you can try
okay The Rook is almost trapped
okay he's just I don't know about those
trades though
oh
well it seems like ding is basically
like I'll win the end game where I at
least I won't lose
he definitely won't lose and he's gonna
go F5 and try to bring this Knight back
to D5 total positional domination
careful H Force hanging though don't
don't don't lose that yet
okay now Knight B6
D5 there's always oh Bishop F6
yep tactics work out for black
here's F5 been making progress amazing
position for black cheese what an
amazing position for black but you're
still gonna have to actually win it and
that's what worries me a little bit uh
uh
oh
there's sacrifices
HG GF
and then is there a sack on F4 uh it
doesn't quite work
like I think white was lost completely
yeah but instead he gets his Queen
around to h8 if nehal holds this I'm
Gonna Leave the commentary Booth I think
now you take and take Levy and then
maybe throw in a check on H4
yeah takes it what about just taking
Queen H1 like what
or even G4 I mean G4 but Queen H1 I
agree with yeah okay apparently it was
nice GF and Bishop H4 yeah yeah just GF
I guess white we'll have to play EF
careful now he's got five seconds to his
bar he's got one bar of connection oh no
oh no and he declined to draw
ing draws
oh no he's got a flag no it's happened
again
oh my gosh 9301
oh oh what to say
and ding just has the worst luck with
his internet
yeah that's brutal
that's brutal you know what what that
reminds me of in a weird way nihal
offering draws it's like when Pavel
teclaf remember that video where he was
falling off the table
yes
and if you ground Patricia just kind of
extends his hand as he's falling off the
table
that's kind of what that reminds me of
like he's he's trying to help him up but
at this point he's too far gone
yeah
I get what you mean well listen
though
it was classy it was it was definitely
classy
um
but uh unfortunately
yeah ding does go down on time 52 of
dingley runs losses have come by way of
flagging which is crazy that's
that's crazy
now I'm supposed to leave because I said
I'll leave the commentary Booth if
if Newhall wins but
I didn't mean that way
yeah no you didn't you didn't mean with
Wi-Fi Gambit
that's tough man that's that's tough is
this what it feels like to commentator
during the red match like he loses like
three points in every match because of
the internet
basically yeah he has historically I
would say on average two or three games
for sure and this just gets more
concerning the shorter the time control
imagine having these problems in in
bullet
yeah
so yeah that is that is unfortunate I
meant stuff for sure
whoa and nihal gives the game back
oh my gosh
what nihal has resigned in three minutes
oh my goodness that honestly
deserves nothing but praise but honestly
I I hope you know nihald isn't doing
good because he feels too bad like
that is
I was not expecting that yeah I mean me
neither I mean that's I thought it was
just life I I but wow
wow wow
let's keep it close
incredible wow that is okay obviously
okay
Daniel hear me out
yeah can you hear me out it's gonna be
crazy right
go ahead nihal it would have been a tied
match
had he lost
right because it was 3-2 so it would
have been three three so should now
resign this game too
he's only gonna give him one on
it would be a bit craziest thing I've
ever seen if you're resigned to in a row
I mean but think about it right like
he's giving him one because he's like
it's not fair that he lost that game but
you know all right all right Nicole's
giving him he's letting him get within
one I'm obviously joking around I mean
that is
very classy I'm gonna be honest if I was
playing against Eric Rosen and he
disconnected I'm taking that point you
better you better believe I'm taking
that point
come on no I think I think in such
situations there shouldn't be like the
expectation that you're supposed to
resign but if you do it it deserves you
know the utmost praise no question about
it
yeah
of course
um of course idiots in chat will think
uh I'm you know being serious but no I
mean it's a very classy move from from
nehal and uh he basically says kind of
like let's let's have a do-over it's a
one-point game one point match
um
but we've seen this before like when
Magnus sacrificed his Queen and then
resigned immediately on move two I think
Magnus won some Award of sportsmanship
for that uh I think it was against ding
actually it was against ding that's what
I'm saying like uh yeah it's happened
before
yes so you know what else has happened
before the line that nihal is currently
playing he follows his cgc prep with
that early Bishop F4 Pawn sack
and of course Wesley so was the one who
took on D4 with the queen
but we've already deviated from that
game
yeah there's this very trendy line cd5
Knight D5 very very sharp stuff
um yeah nehal played this against uh it
was the muscle in game against Wesley I
think he played like this right and then
was a valiant attempt but he didn't make
it happen
oh yeah very interesting point by the
way the timer is Frozen
oh yeah it is
[Laughter]
um
she asked when you said that
okay what did we make of this where is
White's compensation I would say most of
it has to do with the pawn 95 kind of
clamping down on Black's position and of
course you have a lot of King side
promise with the Knight getting into G5
easy play here for white I don't really
believe in this objectively though
no I certainly don't either and I feel
as though this is a perfect bullet
weapon which is it's not exactly praised
for an opening to be a good bullet
weapon but
uh obviously three minute and five
minute is still relatively viable to
play uh in a way where you're down a
pond but have some vague ideas for an
attack
uh if it works it works but if not then
well then you're just going to be 4-4
and smarter chess is completely
Justified at that point right now let's
keep keep in mind everybody it's four
and a half four and a half
it's the smartest chest prediction for
this segment so only half has to do is
hit the resign button right now and then
make a quick draw and actually not right
now then we're probably gonna play one
in two games
so yep if only he knew what the
prediction was I think he would
subconsciously steer the match in that
direction now I agree this is a great
bullet weapon and in in the three plus
one game I think this is something worth
repeating
five plus one I think is borderline
although of course they all played this
against Anish giri uh for the first time
and scored a crushing Victory so it's
also the good memory effect where you
want to repeat the lines that have
brought you memorable victories even if
your opponents are now well prepared
against them you know what I'm saying
I I know exactly what you're saying
it's a nice watch by the way I like your
watch
oh thank you
did you win it off someone in some dark
room like
chess uh matches you know so most of my
watches have been you know from like
tournaments or or gifts this one this is
this one I got myself though it was a
birthday present to myself wait what do
you what do you mean tournaments they
award watches and chess tournaments I
did win one of my like favorite watches
and unfortunately it stopped working but
I won it in the spice cup 2011. it was a
really nice watch
and before that I'd sort of warn you
know like digital watches and I I felt
like a badass you know
wearing a watch that I won in a
tournament
but that that's actually very very cool
because
I mean there's an argument to be made
that watches can appreciate especially
if they get you some very very nice one
right
oh there's super cool no for sure
but I oh I lost I left it at a
basketball game
I was on the the JV basketball team in
10th Grade that's where I left it I left
it in some high school
I'm sorry
that's yeah I I only leave umbrellas in
public places I would cry if I look I
watch a lot of stuff in public places
unfortunately
well nihal is hoping to leave one of his
knights in dingly Run's position either
on D6 or on G5 that's what he's
currently contemplating
um jeez there you go you go there you go
that was what I like to call the Robert
Hess transition I've watched enough
Robert has commentary he's good at
taking the end of any sentence and tying
it into the commentary it's spectacular
it's a skill yeah where is Robert no
you're totally right
that's a good question I don't actually
I don't actually know
listen I enjoy commentary but I would
prefer being in bed right now and
watching you and Robert come and date
you know what I'm saying so we gotta
somebody gotta call up Robert and then
see and see where he's at Queen H5 by
the way mate is almost threatened look
at this defense from dingley Wren
oh look at those Bishops defending F7
now Knight takes H7 almost where I mean
the queen sack almost works but the King
has the h8 square in the end
wait is there Knight F6 check
immediately
is that
worth exploring or maybe just Knight D6
honestly well I I play GF what do you
want
Bishop H7 that I have not quite
determined yeah no it doesn't work
that's okay that's okay
you have higher rate of player bonus so
you just can sacrifice pieces and
he's okay it didn't work out but all
right try at least I tried I think
Knight D6 Knight D6 might be the only
viable move here
uh
yeah I'll move 24 seconds
maybe nihal still feels guilty for the
flagged game maybe he's okay losing two
in a row
I mean geez
and that is a scary move
F6 Bishop H7 and white wins so
very careful made on F7 and Bishop takes
D6 You Again Play Bishop takes H7 and
again why wins
okay Bishop G5 HG right if you had to
eliminate that night
position
[Music]
this position
and ding just grabs the pawn on B2
Savage
how is nihal gonna handle this with six
seconds
uh Knight enough eight never made
it's just never happening
yeah it's a beautiful defense score
honestly or something that James Canty
would say
maybe six we in the mix
he just keeps taking place three that
Queen A3 oh that one's free
Bishop H4 now trying to drive his Bishop
into F6
yes he is but then is there
I don't know what there is actually that
looks very scary and
exchange sacrifice followed by Bishop C6
ding bringing his pieces out in return
two two seconds two seconds
watch out for Rook takes C6 if the
Knight moves out from f8
that yeah nihal will play that and some
yes he will do that
probably not enough even there
whoa whoa whoa whoa oh he wants that
pawn he wants the D6 Pawn
no but now ding is much better he's got
a thousand pawns for the exchange
yeah but the problem is his opponent is
nihal and he's capable of just playing
Bishop E5 Bishop A1 and somehow winning
no already it's starting to look a
little more complicated and the problem
is you would love to play Queen E7 Queen
G5 but you can't because if Bishop takes
D5 and Rook takes D5 so actually maybe
Queen d8 and queen G5 should be
considered
oh that is Bishop H4 though whoa whoa
Knight Queen takes seven
minutes
oh man what a crazy moment Queen takes
G7 and white was already fine
so is ding gonna throw the game now yeah
they're starting to keep going back and
forth and resign
oh my gosh Queen so yeah so just in case
anybody was confused Queen takes G7 was
called the Desperado you were going to
lose your queen anyway so you sacrificed
the queen for a pawn you weaken the
structure you win the queen back okay
this is ridiculous so nihal loses a game
on purpose because he feels bad for
ding's internet connection ding now wins
a game because of a mouse lip
so but I would argue
might be that even after Queen takes G7
the position remained very double-ish
and probably black would have the
Practical Edge given White's clock and
knee-haw is just frustrated that was one
he wants back
I yes I I agree with you and um
I mean the chess gods are just really
they are messing with these two you know
what I mean it's like story of Job story
of new hollanding you know you you is
that is that the way that uh good
intentions are rewarded the chess gods
are punishing the hall they're like you
you you you're messing with a you
messing with the results of these
matchups and um you Mouse look there
Queen G6 I mean we've seen so much
uncharacteristic stuff from nihal we saw
him lose on time and mouse slip I I feel
like we don't ever see any of these
things
I literally was opening my mouth to say
the exact same thing like we are so used
and we're used to seeing this from other
players but Whitney Hall when he gets
into time pressure we we expect like
Perfection which I would totally admit
is an unrealistic expectation he is
human but we often forget that when he
just wins again and again
in complicated positions with just a
couple seconds left on his clock but
maybe nerves
poking their ugly head in this
particular match
the smarter chess prediction states that
this game will end in a draw now what uh
because it's four and a half four and a
half after the five plus one but listen
as a seasoned veteran of watching The
Back to the Future series I know that
any action can potentially you know
affect many things down the line so did
smarter chess anticipate a disconnect a
throne game and then a mouse slip of a
queen
um
I don't know so I don't know what's
gonna happen maybe it'll be five four
I wouldn't put it past smarter chest to
anticipate even that he's defied all
expectations broken All Odds
and and this has just been I can't
believe it's just 4-4 you look at that
score you're like oh they probably have
made a couple of draws it's been a very
positional match
little would you know what we just
witnessed in the last couple of games
yeah wild stuff and another very
aggressive opening here white indicating
yeah very hostile declarations at the
black position with the move F4 as three
pieces are asleep on the queen side
and as always Stockbridge sits there and
laughs at us and
says it's equal
so a couple of clarifications C takes D4
there's Queen takes C8 not technically
Checkmate but white one's material
and if black just nonchalantly plays
well first a knight D7 F5 actually traps
the bishop
and if you play Knight to C6 here maybe
that is the move but you have to watch
out for D takes C5 there
and F5 Bishop H7 check in certain
positions followed by F5 can be a
problem as well
I guess we're about to find out Knight
C6 is on the board
wow just not afraid of anything I mean
F5 yeah just
I mean DC DC looks like a risk-free
option that maybe gives white a small
advantage in the end game
I just want to play F5 F6 I'm really sad
it doesn't work
just you're not fast enough
after the 1965 Queen takes E5
yeah you you don't actually get in to do
anything on G7 you just take on G7 and
nothing happens
um
maybe Queen F2 here by white is a good
idea
of Queen you put attention
and CD I don't know
okay I mean what I like about DC is that
it's it's very risk-free you really
don't want to lose the last game
of of the segment and it is upding's
alley
okay so BC Queen C5
you trade everything black takes on E5 I
don't know how to evaluate that
resulting end game white is a pawn up
but he's got these weaknesses on the
e-file
wow Queen E7
what a cold move right there
yeah these guys are like the
the kings of making these cold moves
that I look at and I go oh yeah that
makes sense I didn't I didn't anticipate
that you know I didn't think about that
I didn't either CB now there's Knight
takes E5 so and if Knight C6 after Rook
C6 the pawn on C5 is pinned so maybe you
take and go B4
and you get into this tug of war over
the C5 Pawn
who wins the tug of war is the question
I'm not sure
probably black what do you see
it's I also really want to play Bishop
A6
but uh-huh
the violent
counter shot night before he uh brutal
so the line that I'm I'm chewing on by
the way just I can show this quickly on
the analysis board Knight C6 Rex C6 B4
bcbc Rook a to C8 and I think black is
totally fine here you're losing C5 and
you've got this long-term weakness on E3
that counter balances the you know
relatively weak isolated Pawn on D5
so maybe there's a move here maybe you
throw in Bishop B5 ah this might be
actually a way to test black because now
if you repeat the line there's C6 and
here black is in trouble
what do you make of that I feel like
we've gone so far off the deep end here
I mean I I confirm your findings
but whether or not this actually occurs
uh is a is another another issue
entirely but yes
the weak E3 Pawn will be counterbalanced
by the fact that the C Pawn could make
it to C6 yes there is an option I I
think it's not entirely unlikely that we
get that exact line because what else is
White gonna do if not Knight takes C6
maybe drop the Knight back to F3 but
again there's Knight to B4 I don't see
an alternative here for ding
he doesn't seem too convinced either
he's going down to a minute I think he
just needs to keep his yep there it is
now he's going for it Bishop B5 come on
you know you want to play five
I think he will play you should be five
and then Rook to B6
is also possible
Wayne takes Pawn you trade you double on
the B file you try to win the pawn back
but all of that is hard to evaluate
huh probably the last game of the five
minute Portion by the way
foreign
yes yes for sure there's no way that
we're gonna get anywhere
another game off unless they just agree
to withdraw for some reason
um
but
it'll likely be the last game and I I
just somehow doubt it's going to end in
a draw I just no it looks like there's
enough
kindling for the fire here
yeah these guys play like they don't
like each other
which is great it makes for very
entertaining uh
you know
content
well ding you know as as Placid as he is
and is you know one of the classiest
guys in chess but he definitely hasn't
forgotten their cgc match he wanted to
go to Toronto I mean
you don't lose a match like that and
then just kind of shrug your shoulders
and say okay you know whatever he has an
opportunity for revenge and he's played
inspired
put together chess
so and nihal always does that
Rook B6 versus Rook C7
yep
which is he going to play but it was
okay Rook B6 played then Kevin takes a
five and game yeah
A4 all right this
okay six F5 whoa there we go
a b A5 intermezzo
wow a protected passer
and White's the only one with winning
chances there Neal drops his Bishop back
okay
Bishop B7
is black holding this comfortably
I think he might be um I think he might
be he's gonna trade the Bishops and rook
and games are drawn even with a one
point disadvantage
okay ding trying to figure out a way to
keep his pawns intact maybe A5 and Rook
F to D1
in response to Rook B5
he goes Rook to A5
hunting for the a pawn
then
I guess he's gonna win
the pawn on E3
uh and then go for the pawn on G2 and H2
once clearly seems to be the idea
so which move are you proposing Rook oh
Rook C7 he goes for activity he says I
don't need the a pawn
I don't need the a pawn I don't even
need the e-pawn I was thinking Rook E7
um wow H3 he's gonna make a run for it
with his King
and H5 in order to be able to play H4
later and cover the king's Escape path
interesting move
here's another time scramble watch the
internet if you're ding
yeah ding is a Madman
I mean runs the risk of losing on time
again you have six played
we're gonna get a bunch of captures here
or not
okay
so maybe King H7 G5 and King G6
why does two pawns up but black has one
final idea which is paralyzed the white
position with something like H4
or Rook F2
but now King G3 maybe oh boy
the thing is White's probably gonna lose
that ape on Rook F5
yep yep
foreign
oh two seconds for ding Rook G5 check is
blacked out like playing for a win
um is not gonna play for a flag he's
gonna try to but
I she's oh look at this repetition
yeah this is hilarious this is nutty
this is one of the craziest like ring
around the rosies I've ever seen that's
in a draw
that it's amazing wow that literally was
Ring Around the Rosie that was hilarious
and that will be the final game of the
segment and uh four and a half four and
a half after nine games of action and
smarter chess predicted it wow a
peaceful resolution Dania to the five
plus one
incredible I cannot believe smarter
chess predicted the score to a T it's
four and a half four and a half what a
topsy-turvy affair at the same time
morning the moment after ding lost his
internet neither player has led
by more than one point I mean it has
just been neck and neck and we've had
games all over the map Levy in terms of
their characteristics we've had some
positional Affairs some crazy tactical
battles everybody you know is Satisfied
by that segment wouldn't you say
absolutely I think I think everybody
that's tuned in to watch this show is
satisfied with everything and you can't
ask for a better start this is the
closest match on paper that we've ever
had in the speed Chess Championship and
it's shaping out to be a crazy one so
epic uh start and finish here to the
five plus one segment Donnie I can't
wait for uh the faster version of The
Blitz
I can't either and we will have a short
break but before we go to that break a
reminder that the second annual chess
kid All-Star finals is coming your way
December 17th the world's top Juniors
who won the chesskit monthly
championships in 2022 will be competing
for the title of Chess kid of the year
they can also win fun prizes like
lessons with GMS and merch from our
store chess gets own fun Master Mike
will hold down the six rounds of the
match on chess TV and the chess kid
twitch Channel tune in on December 17th
at 9 00 a.m Pacific noon eastern time
for the second annual chesskit All-Star
final as well
stay tuned to this match because we will
have an even more epic 60 Minutes of
three plus one here at the speed Chess
Championship round of 16. the match
between New Hall and ding Returns on the
other side of this short break
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done a
hundred percent ad-free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
thank you
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
be your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
[Music]
when Damon first approached me with the
idea of teaching children to play chess
I thought you
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this this is insane
the electricity
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
and we welcome you back to the speed
Chess Championship it's a round of 16.
it's been a pleasure commentating this
fascinating match for you today I'm GM
Daniel nerdinski alongside International
Master Levy Rosman Debbie Rosman it's an
early start but we've gotten caffeine we
needed from the five minute segment of
this match
yeah we did the caffeine equivalent uh I
want you to refer to me forever as just
my full name
and uh I am Levy Rosman no no not even I
am just just Levy Rosman a friendly
reminder of the scores it's deadlocked
which is a good thing because we have
two more sections of action three plus
one one plus one and smarter chess is
right they are all squared after five
plus one so to break that tie down you
we're gonna speed them up a little bit
shave off two minutes of clock time who
do you think that benefits
well my default answer of course is
nihal he's the more experienced Blitz
player he is the better time Scrambler
so again and I've said this for a lot of
these matches he wants this to be tied
going into the bullet I think he would
not mind for this match to be decided by
30 minutes of Bullet at the same time I
think ding has revealed the capacity to
play quickly there were some games when
ding was up to two and a half minutes
and we saw a little bit of slippage Levy
Rosman from nihal sarin in time pressure
and you pointed out how uncharacteristic
that is that could be a very encouraging
sign for ding
yeah listen there's only so many times
nihal is going to throw games out of
sportsmanship if ding's internet gives
out a second or a third time I'm not
sure in the hell is going to continue to
give away points I mean it's sort of
unfortunate but that's that's really how
it goes and I'm hoping for we don't get
to that situation nihal is really being
tested by the by the ethics Gods you
know like uh yeah I don't think any man
needs such
such uh trials and tribulations
um I just hope that ding's internet
right and if
stays up stays strong and I believe
we'll have a first move very shortly
we will indeed I'm trying to remember
who had the white pieces in the last
game I think ding had the white pieces
so nihal will be white what is he gonna
bring to the table Levy are we gonna see
E4 is he gonna go back to a London
system which I think is more likely
given they reduce time control
I don't know could play in English I
don't think he plays englishes at all I
I feel like it might be a London just
get started nice and stable and
yeah it's weird nihal doesn't really
play Knight F3 move one he doesn't Play
Systems where he fee and keros
the king said Bishop I guess
huh
wow here we go yeah not even predicting
his openings predicting his playing
style E4 on the board King's Gambit ow
Rory Lopez Italian no no Italian a
scotch
will you get something new Mainline
are the sneaky Knight D2 thing yes
yeah that's been so popular hasn't it
and this is a pawn sacrifice line which
both players are clearly familiar with
well there's a chance the ding might
even be preparing this at like Tata
steel and World Championship level
yeah that's one of the dangerous things
about playing a world championship
Challenger you never know when he's just
gonna uncork some World Championship
preparation oh sorry I prepared this for
nepo
no it's a very fascinating dilemma for
some of these top players
to have like do I use my prep against
this guy in you know Tata steel rapid
and Blitz do I use it in uh Vikings a
where do I use it I really like this
position for white uh but the bar
doesn't it doesn't think that there's
ain't much in this position for white
I like the idea of this position like on
paper you've got the queen on H5 you've
got compensation on paper but in reality
Black's got the open B file and that can
be used as a major attacking asset I
would even consider Rook B8 in this
position the Knight can jump into E4 so
the wheels can come off the position
super super quickly yaha has to be very
precise here if he wants to prove the
compensation
exactly right and by the way if he loses
this game it's going to be his first
time trailing in the match since one
nothing right it's been a while Knight
A4 yeah wow
hitting B2
a sensible move but what about Rook D4
what is he planning on rookie for
we will never know because the bishop
has now blocked that book
that'll forever remain behind the scenes
in the hall he says I don't mind a queen
trade
that is so fascinating well I do so but
he didn't ask me
so if the Queens come off he's basically
just saying that yes black is up a pawn
but structurally speaking he has some
stupid stuff going on here and he
doesn't have enough compensation
Bishop E7 was blundered for a second but
okay
you know you could still play Bishop E7
if you really wanted to draw you could
make it with Bishop E7 I actually think
he does kind of want to draw at this
point
okay similar idea just go go into the
opposite color Bishop end game and claim
that your increased piece activity gives
white full comp for the pawn which it I
think at this point it does
yeah the doubled C pawns and the D5 Pawn
don't leave such a strong impression but
it it still begs the question of
why you play this opening right I mean
black has to be precise for five or six
moves and
doing sort of did it effortlessly but
maybe he's I mean maybe maybe there's
more to this position than meets the eye
like could just straight up be this case
I think at this point there's a little
bit more than meets the eye so Bishop E7
was possible he decides does nihal to
preserve his light skirt and allow
Knight E4 so he really wants to keep
that Bishop pair alive
I I like that decision
F3 that dark squid Bishop is a is a
beast Bishop G1 maybe all pieces on the
first rank now
the Knight is also a beast by the way
it's just sort of sitting in the center
and controlling all of the key squares
a5a4 obligator removes
yeah fixing the pawn though could be a
weakness in the long run Knight B7
repetition right I was thinking
repetition 96 Bishop C5
if you think about it actually that the
Rooks disappear from the board white has
this idea of putting the bishop on the
E1 A5 diagonal and the Knight is not a
reliable defender of a corner Pawn
weakness
you're absolutely right I mean the
Knight on B7 does not impress me Bishop
do you try to get his money's worth from
that night
I was gonna say do you play Bishop A6 or
Bishop B5 and then Bishop A6 or Bishop
C6
Bishop C6 but he does allow the move d4
also Rook D6 is possible but then he
would take on B7 take on C5 and White's
basically playing a risk-free position
where he's slightly better
it is yes
so this should be seven bishopsy
oh Rook C6 and Rook takes B3
yes exactly
and niho might have missed that he
doubles back to B5 I think given ding's
clock nihal wants to keep all the pieces
on the board for as long as possible
this is kind of okay what about rookie
five and Bishop Elam
hold the black position
subtle move but now if you're moving the
rookie move it to E5 that's just like I
and then you know Allah
might as well sacrifice on G5 also okay
G4
robbing King side space
now rookie five
now rookie five looks even better
because you're making contact with the
C5 Pawn trying to immobilize the Knight
D6 is still possible but didn't end up
losing his entire Queen side there
he will you're going to lose C5 C7 and
D4 and probably A5 uh Rook a rookie C4
I guess black has Rook 88 in the end and
the trade favors black
uh yeah yeah back to E2 very close and
then double on the e-file or something
like that
seems logical logical logical and then
H3 F4 or something yeah I don't know
20 seconds here we go with this again
I know I'm so stressed
so a problem for ding levies that if the
bishop moves from E6 which it just did
rookie seven looks really dangerous for
black
yes it does but maybe I'm exaggerating
ten seconds he takes C7 he wants to
double on the seventh
maybe Rook A7 now is important to stop
A4 stuff
it's just that black has worked B7 whoa
C4 you can't take on Passat that's a
fork
oh my gosh oh my God it's a tilter oh
wait ding it
yeah Rook B7 he has Rook p7 I found a
way to keep his Bishop alive and out B3
Falls
and White's worse
I thought he could have been very
perplexed why no one's taking the pawn
that I want them to take
this is now very likely to end in a drop
but Rook C3 takes C4 and black can
pushed this for a while
yeah Rook D4 never too late to hang a
fork
I'll Rook E4 and Rook E2 almost won a
second Pawn but Whitehead rookie three
now it should be obvious it's not easy
Rook H6 he wins the pawn ah
ah never mind
never mind but H4 impossible to get
white stroke off of H6 so this will just
be a draw
just don't go Rook F6 because the color
the corner Pawn is is
the wrong color if you're white
okay
kind of a good solid working man's game
right there the score is five five
you enjoying the match how are you
feeling
I am very much enjoying the match
I think
I'm enjoying the variety of openings
that we're getting the variety of
different types of positions and
speaking of variety Queen B6 Levy this
is a super fashionable Lion of the
Queen's gamut accepted
yeah but not and it's the crazy
positions
yeah yeah three I haven't seen Knight D5
is pretty automatic there
yeah B3 is like some sort of new idea by
the way Queen D4 is a free Pawn I mean I
don't know what is happening
yo what's up Queen D4 Knight ge2 I guess
is the idea
or Knight F3
and you're probably right Knight F3
looks better
he takes the other Pawn
just Knight F3 or you take back on C4
what's going on I feel like there's so
many hanging pawns here and none of them
are being captured
yeah Nell's just like I'm not gonna take
your Pawn nope
but okay I mean he's got the outside
passer on A5 I kind of like Black's
position here I'll be honest
what do you think
um
I agree I like the past Apon I think
there's good long-term prospects on the
queen side
Knight A4 is a nice way to blockade it
though I don't know
yeah on the other hand there's always on
the other hand whites just got a lot of
piece activity
Bishop takes B4 and Knight C5
can leave Black's pieces hanging and of
course there's eventually the
possibility of going D5 especially if
black fails to complete his Queen side
development in timely fashion
uh completing your queen side
development here looks
very challenging I mean if dingley run
actually you know poses you some very
concrete issues but uh
like Knight C5 or something but 95 yeah
or Bishop takes before first
mm-hmm
and now
I mean even 90 no 92
oh my God there's this really cool line
actually
so I was thinking if we could pull up an
announcement Knight D2
Bishop takes C4 and Rook B1 was my idea
but black has the ridiculous move Bishop
to B3
and if you take with the queen you drop
the Knight if you take with either of
the other two pieces then you sever the
connection between the queen and the
Knight you lose your knight and A4
anyways
irrelevant but interesting
miscible I mean definitely missable
definitely missable
back to life position
yeah he's taking his time in this
position
maybe 95. one should
95 is very interesting yeah he kind of
doesn't want to take on A6 right like he
but if you back up here with white like
Bishop B3 black just gets some I mean is
it really so natural development like
Knight c6d5 and it isn't black almost
lost
oh my God no I agree I think you should
play night I think you should play
Knight D7 to cover I mean if Knight C5
is a pretty devastating night jump here
so I would go Knight D7 with black and
move the queen back to D6 if necessary
and it is going to be necessary if white
goes Rook V1
B1 yeah oh my God is not trapped no but
then rookie three right
oh the bishop is hanging takes A2
yeah even the line still continues Rook
B2 and Rook C3
there's Queen F1 at the end and White's
slightly better in the end game oh my
God yeah
oh that's so funny Chad don't worry
about it you guys you guys did you guys
just keep doing your thing you guys are
great
yeah exactly don't worry about it we
just we just
we're just too
slightly under caffeinated bozos trying
to you know move other people's pieces
that's what's going on here uh I like
White's position a lot though
I likewise position
a lot
this has been like phenomenal prep by
dang the decision to go B3 I think a
very wise movement Blitz but look at his
clock
yeah he's down a minute
there should be three right on D5
and I think nihal might be spinning his
way out of the most difficult part of
the game
or do you think white still has a strong
initiative Bishop C2 I I I I think white
does but White's uh got too low time and
I think this is like vintage nihal stuff
right here
I mean I think I just uh-huh
I just I mean even by the way even if
the clocks were reversed if you if if he
had 29 seconds with black versus one
minute with white he's just so good at
defending this chaotic nonsense
and the thing is not even yeah not even
bailing out yep what's up
no it's just I'm having a hard time
figuring out a move for black because if
you move your queen back then white
drops the bishop back to C2 and if white
can get rid of Black's light squared
Bishop White's got this C6 Square for
his Bishop the knights are not very good
when they've got zero anchor points in
the center and in the blink of an eye
nehal is now down on the clock this is a
big chance for ding I think to strike in
this game
let's see if he can capitalize
see
okay it's on the board oh Knight C3 and
maybe now Bishop C2 no he goes 94th he's
chasing the queen around
just push D6
just
shove that but D6 open up the bishop
no this is amazing stuff I mean the pawn
is is just being used as a barrier from
the queen side to the king side look at
the hall and the hell just kind of went
like how do I have nothing here oh
and Knight C5 another dagger and now
black has three seconds the Pawn's gonna
be on D7 in the blink of an eye and
there it is
oh where's the win 95 oh just Relentless
Relentless seven now Knight F7 oh just
take it take it to the eight and finish
it up 96 96 96 96. oh
ding okay
oh G3 such a clinical move
and there we go she takes the lead it's
sexy that just forces the Queen off the
bishop I'm just I'm so impressed with
how he has handle himself in time
pressure All Things Considered
oh yeah I mean absolutely all things
considered it was a very stressful match
six five lead change
last time ding LED it was one nothing
and we we just do not go above a one
game margin except for when nope uh
during the Run oh and we have our
Marshall so we have
this is ding Loren's bread and butter
it really is and this is a chance for
dink to break the cycle if he wins this
game it is not fun to be facing a
two-point deficit
you know only for the first time like
over 90 minutes into the match so let's
see if nehal plays with an abundance of
caution here
and an interesting position she hasn't
accepted the pawn sec
no no no no no he has not
um which in the Marshall can lead to a
lot of fun for black now it's just a
normal game
it's a normal game and it's hard to say
if the pawn on D4 is a strength or a
weakness black is the space advantage
but in such cases you also sometimes
bite off more than you can chew
and the pawn is not a hindrance to the
white position at all white will play
Knight F3 Bishop F4 and just sort of
move around the pawn this is not not
really restricting anything but
um
also possible
yep
rookie five I think yeah Bishop F4 or
Bishop Chief maybe bishop G5 there's a
case to be made for that move to put
some pressure on the Knight it just
feels like the position's very equal
uh e45
Spanish 20 moves of prep equal game
chess
welcome to chess yes
I'm not sure there's an activity that's
more disconnected between the elite and
the the newbies I mean it's like
completely different universes you know
these like within e45
not just anything I mean any I mean any
activity like at least you know in
tennis if a new player watches a
experienced player you're like oh I see
what he's doing I just can't do it I'm
not fast enough but I kind of see his
footwork in chess it's like I don't know
what they're doing but I like the
commentary so I'm just here having a
good time it's so far apart in
you know what you're actually supposed
to do at a lower level and a high level
these guys just busting out 20 moves of
Martial Theory and
is this this is a martial but not
accepted right it's like he went into
the Marshall but he doesn't take the pun
is that what this is yeah almost one
could say a decline a declined partial
yeah he now he didn't play whoa Marshall
by the by I feel like he's misplaying
this is nihal Knight F6 to D5 kind of
leaves the G4 Knight in the dust and it
actually threatens the move H5 trapping
the Knight
so it seems to me
that after 95 or maybe even Knight F6 to
D7 in order to keep the diagonal
unobstructed
I feel like ding is just so comfortable
in these types of positions he knows
every idea and Knight T5 is on the board
yeah and I think nihal is grabbing at
his own face
indicated that a mosquito did not bite
him but I think rather indicated that he
realized this and I don't know G4 is
just sort of
it's just sort of standing there and
it's a terrible piece
well you said it not me all right that
was don't judge it right it's doing its
best
and uh it is legitimate I don't even
know what Nicole is going to do here
like can he just like start going crazy
a takes B5 Rook takes A8 something like
that
yeah I would trade everything on A8 and
then I would try to find some way to
meet H5 maybe with a sacrifice on H6 and
then follow that up with Queen H5 but
that is very hard to engineer and he's
trying to engineer something like this
he's down to 36 seconds again
and I don't think he's surviving this
with you know five seconds for the rest
of the game
25 seconds now he doesn't see a move
and he does oh
wow oh he wants queen G4 and I think he
wants this move Queen to F5 to try to
pry the Knight away from D5 so you have
a check on F6
a incredible idea wait but there but
there's C4 there
oh there is C4
so does he want Bishop takes H6 simply
after GH
yeah we're about to find out
I think so and queen G4 right
it takes a little bit more time here to
figure it out
he doesn't have a lot of it left I think
Bishop takes H6 you just go for the two
pieces for The Rook
I don't see another move
yep
disagreed by the way
yeah maybe just because of King h8
Black's minor pieces are massively
powerful
yeah oh my God just king of shape
oh my gosh there is a gorgeous tactic
here gorgeous
and I'll show it after the
93.93 and Bishop H2 yeah
ridiculous
uh and like bishop and ridiculous
this is a crazy crazy game
well now it's a three result game Levy I
mean you could lose control of this with
black easily
oh I would have lost control of this a
long time ago
um I think I think d8 was the move
Queen G5 no then Knight takes H3 but
Queen f
incredibly strong
yeah ding might lose oh my gosh oh no oh
my queen at Queen F6 is just a massive
mate threat and you can't defend against
it easily
oh my gosh
no he's his position's falling apart
suddenly
wow
he just might have forgotten the queen
F6 if you move the queen back to d8 you
drop the Knight on F4 and you're just a
pawn down with a ruined King side
on the clock
it's it's re it's unbelievable it's
ridiculous
and ding is now running out of time
F6 Rook takes a eight and rookie eight
yep no oh you should take you to the
pawn he should have taken to the pawn
oh my God you would have saved the tempo
so is it Bishop what is the win
I think it's Bishop H2 and then Bishop
takes G2 and you drive the king out to
the e-file and trade Queen's baby with
Queen E5 Queen E5 oh no or that 58 58 no
Queen E5 no there's no move he's gonna
flag
oh my God
what did we just see
oh my God the move oh I think the move
might have been Bishop G7 check
oh stop
get this out of here okay I have to pull
that game up
I'm sorry just really quickly
if I may
the move in the final position for white
was no it was Rook to A6 that was the
only way to keep the tension
but in this position when nihal took on
H3 with the queen Levy the move was just
King to F1
if you can believe that
actually I'm white
just because you know like sometimes
when they sacrifice a piece and you just
say no I'm not gonna touch it and
actually you're winning here because the
only check is Bishop G2 wow
crazy and here you just it's just
overwhelm I mean everything hangs up
seven hangs The Rook hangs and uh black
and resign but the hall ends up taking
with the queen that gives black the
tempo he needs to orchestrate counter
play
incredible topsy-turvy affair
but at the end of it ding is up two
points for the first time in this match
okay back we go to the next call nihal
has not won a game
since
ding flagged because of his internet and
then nihal gave him the next game and
then he lost the next game and then they
made two draws and now he's lost the
next two games
so he hasn't won a game in like an hour
ever since
giving ding a game back crazy
yeah I mean quietly
imperceptibly ding has been dominating
this match
and he's been dictating matters on the
board he's been
getting the kinds of openings he wants
very consistently I think that's
something that's important to pay
attention to he's getting really nice
positions with both colors and he's
forcing nihal to keep making changes in
the opening
and even here I think ding has just a
solid positional advantage
and it's only you know move 13. we have
a BOGO Indian
yeah and honestly what this just means
big picture is that you should just
never be nice to anybody right
just yeah take everything for yourself
always put yourself first and you know
never pick anybody up kind of a thing
because look what look how you look how
the world rewards you
I'm gonna be brutally honest in an SEC
match I would not have had the class to
to do what Neil did I would have been
way too tempted by you know the juicy
morsel
offered me by my opponent
yeah you know what I'm saying yeah it's
very easy it's very easy to look at it
both ways I mean in many ways nihal was
very fine I think giving it up because
he was already up one he kind of thought
ah you know
it's like
it's still a one game match
um but he hasn't won a game since then
and I'm not no he is not even sure he's
I'm not sure he's even played like up to
his standards so tough it's tough but
the biggest Gap in this match is right
now because the other one doesn't count
the other time this game this match was
uh two games apart it was four two and
that was a fake four two it was four
three three moves later
so this is a huge game an absolutely
huge game and I actually like the way
Neal has handled
the last couple of moves he's covered
all of the critical squares on the C
file and he's got a lot of ways to
improve his position I would start with
the bishop B7 to A6 get the bishop on a
slightly more active Square double Rook
Sunny 8 and at that point you're already
have having to think about exchange
sacrifices on E3 which could be pretty
devastating in fact Rook 88 actually
just flat out threatens Rook takes E3
Rook E3 and I mean that's just it's
gonna be it's gonna be Checkmate soon
position is completed of course but
do you start with before
it does wait is white just flat out in
trouble here
I think so
Queen D2 94 I just realized oh my God
you have to go Queen B3
ah you have to no if I I don't know if I
would oh yeah because rookie three right
wow but then black can play A4 and
deflect the queen and then take on E3
black might be winning here and
apparently there's like a computer-ish
defense
but I don't know if ding is going to
find this with 40 seconds left
wait no Queen Exchange
yeah yeah yeah oh my goodness wait what
was just dead in the water now
the defense I can rewind a little bit
was Queen B3 A4 we can bring up an
analysis board here
um as as Neil is going to try to convert
this extra exchange Rook takes you
through and now only move Queen A4 to C6
and the point is that after the queen
trade the obvious Point who will ever
miss this the Knight hangs The Rook
hangs and the E6 square is protected by
the white Bishop so you don't have
rookie six I think ding is just out of
form I think he definitely should have
seen this it's kind of kind of a tragedy
that that he wasn't able to find Queen
B3 Queen A4 Queen C6
and not capturing on E3 yeah very very
bad stuff here yes no business
he has no business challenging the world
championship title really on the basis
of Badness alone
yeah that's Despicable Me I mean I think
like probably like one in three
Spectators watching the stream right now
would have seen that so honestly the
players have no excuses
there will be a halftime break after
this game folks
um as we hit the 30 minute Mark 30
minutes left in the three plus one
segment and then half an hour of bullet
you do not want to miss the rest of this
match I think it's going to be
topsy-turvy all the way through but can
nihal nail the final nail in the coffin
here Levy he needs a couple more
accurate moves and he needs to find a
way to create a past Pawn on the queen
side that would that will do it
that will do it
yeah for A3 and
ah you can start with B3 you can also go
Rook e to B7 on the next move
yeah you you don't want to hang D5 but
you're also not really in a rush and
ding only has 14 seconds
wow yeah and now A4 just push and now
Sac D5 you don't care about anything
except the passer
you can even take on D5 and just play A3
you can probably even sack The Rook
yep what and okay he just goes back to
B8 he wants okay he does he didn't want
that F6 discovery
A3 wasn't that just winning
Bishop takes B7 A2 wow
that was very pretty
yeah but this is also handily handily
just why is he waiting so long to take
the night
fine yeah just get it off the board but
don't go A2 I wouldn't go A2 here
because white can sack the Knight and
white has you know a couple more pawns
left for the uh for the Rook yeah Rook
C7 is very accurate
okay but okay not over yet
king king of six
and there it is big big big win for
knee-hole with the black thesis
essentially on-demand Levy that was
super impressive
super impressive is an understatement I
mean just amazing stuff there
um he just doesn't die
he just doesn't die
no he doesn't he's like amazing he's
coming back
is
just uh I mean just the second that we
thought the ding had a good spot in the
match two-game lead maybe building on
three nehal just strikes back
immediately and it's seven to six
it is seven to six indeed it was a
pivotal victory for knee Hall but ding
still holds a one-point lead and still
holds the momentum one could argue given
the overall trend of the second half of
this match well we will have the second
half of the three-minute portion ladies
and gentlemen coming your way very soon
so do not go anywhere we'll give the
players a chance to refill their coffees
their Waters take a couple of breathers
and we will be back on the other side of
this break here at the speed Chess
Championship with more three plus one
action from dingley Ren versus nihal
sarin stay tuned
foreign
[Music]
first approached me with the idea of
teaching children to play chess I
thought you want to do what
but how are you going to do that and the
more we talked about it the more he laid
out the plan we tried some things and 15
years later we have a fabulous program
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
as he's hyping himself up I'm sure he's
walking back and forth in his hotel room
like Daniel Cormier before a fight
yelling let's go D.L let's go DL let's
go you know just hyping himself up he
just seems to be pacing back and forth
ruminating about what went wrong uh in
that 13th game of action Daniel this is
everything we wanted from a match isn't
it he's ruminating in his hotel room
yes um let's just forget I ever said
that this is everything we wanted as we
look at ding's player card
I mean he's just so consistently
underestimated as a blitz player
and he defeated Alexander grishok who
himself is a former World Blitz Champion
his SEC match record is solid and in
2021 he reached the semi-finals and
let's not forget how close he was Levy
to defeating Hikaru Nakamura it
literally came down to the last game I
had to call that match it was one of the
craziest SEC matches I've ever called
and I've called quite a few of them
yeah I remember
um
I remember pausing what I was doing that
day to watch the conclusion of the
dinghikara match it was just
spectacular action back and forth and it
doesn't get any better than this it's
amazing to see that nehal sarin is
putting up such a monster fight against
him as well and uh again I will
reiterate it for people who are just
joining and even if you've been watching
Today's Show I believe this is the
closest match we've ever had in the
speeches Championship on paper because
smarter chess cannot uh predict a draw
you cannot predict it a match will be
drawn so it literally comes down to one
game and thus far it's playing out
exactly the way it's supposed to
it is indeed I mentioned earlier that
Neal doesn't like to finchetto his King
King side Bishop he says take that
commentator he plays a double fan keto
setup so sort of a king's Indian attack
with the pawn on C4 of course in the
traditional Kia uh you you normally push
E2 E4 so another very kind of tame setup
which Levy one would think kind of plays
into Ding lurant's hands he likes these
types of solid positions a lot
yes
I agree do we have our first
weird ready Larson kind of a thing and
it's going to be a long traditional game
this does suit New Hall style a bit and
this kind of slows down the pace of the
match
I agree yeah an interesting choice for
sure
so the only thing I know Levy is that
black has this idea of Bishop D6 and
then just driving the e-pawn down the
board and that can be really unpleasant
so you all puts an end to that with 95.
ding loves these kind of odd retreating
moves where he just holds on to the
position
and uh he's very good at them
yeah that's an interesting observation
and I think he's gonna go Knight f60 D7
that's why he put his Bishop
specifically on f8 to protect G7 and
maybe the Knight can travel
to B6 and then Knight A4 is not that
easy to stop actually
oh no it's not
no it's not oh my gosh it might be six
Queen B3 you can still play Knight A4 he
puts his Queen on B6 though so it's a
moot point
yeah I don't it's very strange he's not
going Knight B6 Knight A4
okay I guess he has something else in
mind I like I like nehal's position I
like his pressure I like how the queen
side pressures the king side and on the
diagonal
would you go C5 here or keep the tension
with the pawn on C4
but it'll probably keep attention I
don't know maybe B5 even
looks nice
as does B5 definitely has to be
calculated
I always struggle to make progress in
these kinds of positions I feel like you
just make all of the low-hanging fruit
types of moves and then it's like when
do you break through Magnus just plays
like H4 in a position like this and
magically has the Breakthrough oh shoot
when H3
baby baby version of the uh aggressive
line that we were looking at
okay
Knight C5 here maybe
hmm
and who stands to benefit from this
tension on the queen side
I want to like say moves and suggestions
but I also kind of want to pause and
think about the position
for thinking
okay he takes some C6 yeah he's gotten
like nothing when he plays this kind of
Ultra solid type of Chess ding is very
good at like neutralizing this
maneuvering kind of style games
but the same question to Black that I
asked of white okay the Knight is nice
on C5 but how do you improve he moves
back to D7
so perhaps dig doesn't have to do
anything at all he just kind of shuffles
back and forth
waits for the perfect opportunity to
maybe get all the heavy pieces off the
board and just offer a draw
I think that's what we're headed for
yeah kind of I think I think nihal
really should stay away from
these sort of Knight F3 b3s
uh but he's sort of poking and prodding
and he's just seeing what he can get
and he's very very sharp even in the 20
and 30th move
he can apply pressure for a very long
time so
okay it goes back to C2 and I thought
there was DC Knight C4 and Knight D3 but
93 for some reason
I think Rook D1 yep exactly right that's
an instructive line
a little trap
and I guess the Zen of Neil's play is to
try to get ding into time pressure but
ding is not biting he's keeping a a
solid advantage on the clock
and he's not being overly
perfectionistic in these types of
positions which brings a lot of players
down you know they just spend 30 40
seconds when there are three or four
Alternatives that keep an equal position
ding's not doing that and he's handling
this super well Rook A8
and I think we're headed toward peace
or maybe not
it's just
and if shredding that line of equality
sure G6 Bishop F3 Bishop H7 Bishop G2
as equal as a position can get
hmm
what do you make of this I've just been
are we gonna see fireworks
very important everybody drink some
water while we wait for Wow F6 is a very
weakening move but might be fine
yeah F6 what is the the motivation
behind this move well you're blunting
the bishop on C3 and you can also drop
the light squared Bishop back to F7
maybe he's actually provoking neho maybe
he's trying to play Neil's clock here
how about them apples uh my boys
one doesn't just play nihal's clock my
my brother
[Laughter]
hello today Paul plays his own clock
yeah today nehal flagged and also Mouse
lived so
anything is possible I feel like the
position hasn't changed at all in the
last 15 moves the only thing that's well
the heavy pieces are off the board the
clock though is now down to 13 seconds
but that is an eternity in a position
that's this simple for Newhall
exactly but it's it's so symmetrical I
mean it's just so even
I mean what are you doing here yeah dig
might be preparing E5 I think ding's
playing for a win at this point or like
casually he's not gonna make any
super risky moves but I think he
actually might go E5 and quite likely
actually that he plays it here I agree
I mean I I do not disagree with you but
Knight A5 is on the way uh oh and queen
A4 and you're starting to hit the C6
spawn and things are heating up a little
bit yep yep we take C6 oh trade in DC
draw
CDC
it was fun while it lasted King h8 okay
seven King G1
wait there was Bishop takes E5 but okay
anyways
Bishop takes E5
whoa there was Bishop B5 again and he
would ruin upon
unless I was missing something
there might there might have been
something there but I I don't I don't
know exactly what it was is ding gonna
play on ding
no no this is a dead dry I think a draw
for
is forthcoming from Ding and nihal
declines it maybe he didn't see it
he might have or maybe
yeah he wants to milk some time
I don't know about this he might be
worse
yeah he he's lucky he has this reroute
to F2 and draw agreed yeah okay fair
enough no point in continuing
hey that was like fun for three moves I
thought it could get spicy when ding
played E5 but then they found a way to
liquidate
yeah that was sort of boring but we're
allowed a couple of boring games in an
otherwise very fun match
oh for sure
and again this E3 Bishop E2 line who was
playing it which was it the um
match from yesterday in which we saw
this line
there was an SEC match in which no they
they kept repeating this setup with
white I don't remember who it was
anyways E4 in this position is actually
the best move according to the engine
you're playing a king's Indian a Tempo
down Levy but the logic is that the
Knight on D7 is an inferior version for
black
yeah this is
there was a book written like 10 years
ago by Axel Smith
and it was called E3 poison
and oh it was just and it was just how
to play these Queens Pawn positions with
E3 against everything every opening
grunfeld King's Indian slav
and yeah in a lot of those positions you
would play an E3 King's Indian and then
play E4 like five moves later and it
looks really stupid but you you actually
move order black out of certain King's
Indian defenses it's very interesting
yeah no it definitely is and and the
engine approves of it now this position
I've had with black but I Tempo down
like imagine white making two moves in a
row here and that really is a game
changer white would play Bishop E3 and
queen D2 here you potentially have the
possibility of pushing D5 but I guess D5
there's some sort of tactics with Knight
takes C6 so no question in my mind that
white is better objectively but this is
a good Blitz system for black lots of
Tricks here
yeah you can always double up you can
play like c1o B3 and so on and just
slowly try to improve and
I like these positions by the way there
might be five stuff coming
there always is you always have to
consider that move I think if you play
it here black can take and go Queen C6
and the worst is behind him
but definitely should be thought about
on every move because slowly improved
positions
sounds like you were using a voice
changer uh but it basically was
yeah G4 might be on the way
I think Knight takes C6 is actually not
out of the question get the bishop pair
but it does relinquish some of the
pressure on the center it allows The
Rook to move into E6 and it's a good
Defender
and there's B3
if I could get this position with white
every game I ever got to play with white
I would only play White for the rest of
my life I mean the position is just so
so good it seems like you have all the
plans in the world all the time in the
world
and
I mean just so so many creative ways to
attack the black position
and then lose
it is and you do and I agree but
oftentimes that's what a lot that's what
forces you to sink a lot of time whereas
black and just go like Bishop E6 to C8
and H7 H5 black can make a lot of low
stakes moves and keep the status quo
the argument being that the ball is in
White's Court there's Bishop C8
yep
E7 and back C7
why why not A3 B4 I don't understand
that's just not
hey
going back to C7
repeat moves Maybe
maybe we'll have to give an H4
yeah yeah white needs to find a way
forward I mean F4 a little spicy Knight
H5 there's Bishop takes d8 hitting the
queen
so you might have to go back to E7 here
but then
white can just drop the queen to H4
lebby and this isn't like an eternal pin
this is getting real nasty for black
yeah but I feel like nihal is like the
the right man to
get out of this situation you know what
I mean
if there's going to be one man on Earth
for sure
there's quinnish for him for sure
maybe you can get away with some weird
tactics like H6 I've seen this idea
before Bishop H6 and Knight F takes E4
yeah I was just gonna say that
oh my gosh that doesn't work there's 94
Knight C5 and Knight C6
wait let me show this something else
really quickly duh I mean Knight takes
C4
takes takes Knight takes E4 now if you
take the Knight white takes the bishop
and white one's a piece takes Knight C5
DC and the winning move is Knight takes
C6 because you take on E7 with a check
uh
uh what an incredible tact oh my gosh
it's like literally just a buzz saw
through the forest and just completely
yeah exactly just put the meat grinder
on I think Neil spent some time
calculating it and ultimately for that
reason decides for Knight cd7 she's
maybe just F4
like let's go
oh he's preparing H6
look at him go
yep the ship is now under attack
I think nehal is about a nehal's about
to make a comeback
I'm already impressed with his ability
to hold the position together but all of
this is taking five seven seconds off
his clock and again I want to point out
ding's time management is excellent he
just keeps that time Advantage because
he knows that he can't let things get
down to a flat out total time scramble
and I'm super impressed by that
yeah
but nehal's ability to just
guard things without over committing and
I mean just
I mean all right there we go here comes
ding here we go F5 F6 is a massive
positional threat
and he might play F5 anyway
but then black goes to G5 and gets this
big E5 Outpost for either the bishop or
the Knight
it's my it's my idea from the other day
I even want to go G5 now it's probably
losing but
yeah oh yeah I remember that you were
like as obsessed with that idea yeah I
really okay
wow black is fine Bishop E5 F6 oh my
gosh
ding is unhappy
he's unhappy his clock is unhappy I
would go Knight B1 Knight D2 and Knight
F3 try to get that Bishop off of E5 at
all costs he's gonna lose he's gonna
lose he it I mean queen G7 H5 G4 like
something
Queen she's 70.
H5 white will play G4 and plug the hole
in the king side two seconds go make a
move oh never mind I thought he was
gonna play King f8
he's building up the pressure now on the
queen side
when we have a trade and there's your
move don't go Chief King f8 King E7 and
some rookie shade stuff could be there
uh oh oh
wait but now the H file opens I would
have taken back with a pawn Levy he
blunder Z4
oh my goodness you're right
Knight G3 check
oh my God is he not losing you
draw a repetition no he proposed for it
no but this has to be losing Knight back
to G3 and 92 again
what what is going on I'm stuck in a
Whirlpool here
I don't understand what's happening it
might be repeating and making a draw no
oh my God dang but ding is just getting
handled here Knight takes C5 and Rook
takes D6 no way no way F6
no it's winning for black king H6 the
king escapes the checks and Mike gets
mated
we see one I didn't can't believe it
ding can't believe it and nihal sarin
wins with black and it's a tied match
once again
you called it and the thing is I I don't
want to say it was never in doubt Levy
but Yeehaw is just so much better in
these all-out chaotic scrambles he's
just he just doesn't make one move
blunders that's the difference like he
manages to play in those situations
somehow without making obvious tactical
mistakes
no it's just spectacular I just knew it
was coming I just knew it was coming I
if you do not beat me up in the hall
like seven times you will just lose
you just you can there was one critical
moment there was one critical moment
where nihal captured on H3 and ding
could have recaptured with the pawn and
gotten the open G file but those
subtleties are impossible to incorporate
when you've got two seconds you're
literally just focused on not losing on
time somehow nehal is able to also come
up with deep ideas
yeah and he doesn't just play like tide
he doesn't just play quick moves that
are bad I mean it's yeah it's it's
surreal here we go I mean this is this
is why you're watching
this SCC season has been such a treat
and you know we're just getting started
we got Carlson carwana we got so many
epic matches this time around
and this match can go in a million
different directions right now
amazing stuff okay
so we have a real Lopez another relative
relatively tame position it almost looks
like a svechnikov with the bishop pair
and the possibility of F5
yeah dark Squad Bishop on that diagonal
and F5 looking very nice for black but
I like things position for sure
when steps away from the PIN
maybe Rook C8 to keep the tension
before you play F5 it seems kind of
smart okay he just decides to take which
I don't I don't like that oh that's the
idea chop the night off before it gets
to D5 huh
exactly but this is I think this is a uh
just a way to stabilize the position now
it's equal I mean queen D3 black has of
course the weakness on D6 much like in
the Sicilian but compensated by the
general piece activity and the presence
of this F7 F5 Pawn break which you you
should play very judiciously right if
you played too early you weaken your
king and it does more harm than good
yes you should play it judiciously just
like the move Queen H6 very judicious
move I I know what judicious means
um
judging based on the context clues you
know I uh I don't think Queen j6 is a
judicious move I think it's a
just an aggressive one what's a good
word for aggressive like a better word
for aggressive you got one
bellicose
get the what
defined like it comes from it comes from
the word uh belly I think it's Latin for
war like you for the word belligerent I
have okay
Antebellum before the war anyways right
all right I'm nerding I think the word
bellicose is the most impressive word
you have ever used like in our like that
is you know sometimes you say words and
I look legitimate I'm not joking I'm not
like sabotaging my own intelligence for
entertainment I like legitimately like I
didn't know the word foible for example
um and people in chat were like oh
everybody knows foible because you know
it's cool for chats like act smarter
than the person on the on the screen on
this screen or whatever I don't think a
single person in the in the chat knows
the word bellicose that was just a
spectacular word I mean wow I like that
word that's Holocaust thank you the
greatest word you've ever said in our in
our commentary I mean consternation
foible but bellicose that's wow
yeah
Levy knows five words like no one knew
that word that's a brilliant word uh you
win you just win I'm amazing I'm deeply
touched
now everybody's gonna use that word when
the people in the chat come to their
cocktail parties tonight or go back to
their parents they have another word
with which to impress them I wonder how
many people are gonna actually use that
word today probably quite a few I I will
be using that word moving forward
you cannot say a movie is bellicose you
can well your your behavior I think you
can say your behavior is bellicose like
aggressively or like warlike it what it
actually means is a warlike
warlike
amazing yeah like nihals Rooks on the D
file are pretty bellicose I don't know
attacking D6
amazing
so in the meantime I think Levy this has
gotten rather rather unpleasant or Mr
ding
yeah this match has lived up to all the
hype that Brazil Croatia has not lived
up to I'm I'm being informed that that
match is just nil nil and that matches
hardly uh exemplifying any sorts any
signs of being done
this matches nil nil too seven and a
half seven and a half basically the same
as nil nil right right seven seven would
be would be the same yeah
um I like very much the pressure on the
D6 Pawn for white
before now
some before restricting the Knight great
positional move
but you drop C3 and D4 please also you
know what oh yeah E4 also hangs I would
consider H5 at the right my name is
Queen A3 come back
prepare for round two
but that's not what you want to play you
want to go like Rook D5 you know
something more bellicose would be called
for here
I've lost my interest you gotta you
gotta give me more big words
I gotta give you a new word I'll think
of one well right now is gonna give us
some moves
yeah moves is a word I at least
understand
um D5 that's something I understand
yes so we intake C3 what exactly is the
follow-up
Rook D3
like rotate The Rook the other way but
Knight C5 is coming at some point
rotate the Diagon the juicer
now those those are the high level words
we come here for
you know what crazy idea exists here H5
G5 and then rookie five using the X-ray
on the sixth strength exactly rookie
five Knight G5
but knee Hall allows
what to see allow the Knight to jump
into C5 not really because then you drop
D6
I don't know another time scramble and
here we go again it's happening again
it's happening again
uh oh Rook D6
ah seven he wants Knight takes E4
and White's works are in trouble
suddenly yeah just go back to D1 rookie
six or Rook D3 yep
oh this is so sharp
ding takes another Pawn E4 orking the
Knight but rookie three and rookie eight
check you can't take it
there's a mate and now you've got to
move your knight to D4 oh in 96
one is a problem
black snide is also dangling Rook C1 is
a huge threat A5
forcing the Knight away again
oh God and F5 ding making progress
H5 I think
sack The Exchange only chance for white
no way
don't blunder with Queen C1 easy to
blunder your queen here 55 Queen A1
though
correct Queen H1 me Queen H1 open H1
this also wins this also wins oh God
no he's got a flag oh my God oh my God
oh my God he's gonna what no he flies
oh he flagged oh dingly run Flags oh
Queen G7 97 king h8 and the King escapes
the checks and black wins
two teenage one earlier
oh another one oh my goodness I mean how
do
is happening
well we know exactly how it keeps
happening actually
at times
it must connection I mean he might just
have panicked in that position and not
seen a way to escape the checks I
actually think that was more likely yeah
that's very important he didn't lose
that game because of Internet he lost
that game because
his Flags he's just that's what happens
that's just the lack of experience and
again it's not like ding is bad in time
scrambles Levy he outplayed me all
completely when both players were down
to 10 seconds it just extended across
15 moves it's just like only a matter of
time before any L comes up with the
trick or he forces you into a situation
where you panic
you're absolutely right and he is
it doesn't go down until 70 80 moves
have passed
wow
yeah he's uncheckmatable
but he only leads by one that's the
encouraging thing for ding again nobody
able to get separation in this match
this is gonna be the last game of the
three minute portion yes it will by the
way we we were told that actually his
connection during that game and
throughout that game was was full bars
so just a bit of panic a bit of
you know that's what happens you lose on
time sometimes when you get no you got
no time on the clock that's sort of how
it works
yeah in your heart just stopped like
there's nothing crazier than watching a
clock go down in a Time scramble those
three seconds disappear in a heartbeat
just like instantly
to make moves
but he keeps his foot on the gas pedal
and he's better again this move Bishop
A6
like depriving the black Bishop of the
B7 square and E4 D5 is coming to a
theater near you or maybe even DC
opening up the D file
yeah I uh
I also don't know this is very
unpleasant yeah
he's had a lot of these early opening
positions that were super Pleasant for
him ding
actually
um Levy a very instructive mistake here
if we could bring up the announcement
board would be Bishop to E5 I think and
it would allow Knight takes C5 Rook
takes d8 and he's played it I thought it
was a mistake because black gets a ton
of compensation here but maybe ding says
Hey I just go Rook D1 and I'm fine it's
on the board
let's go back to the live position oh
this is literally on the board
whole thing is on board
so the argument is P1 is actually a
super important move
does black want to trade Rooks I don't
think so
maybe on his own terms maybe Rook C to
D7 to keep the D file under control
yes that seems
sophisticated and so now the question is
does black have a defensive Fortress
some of us don't believe in fire by
black E5 maybe or
A5
I was thinking briefly about F5 but that
seems overly weakening maybe just
Queenie too
and I really don't want to weaken the E6
Pawn
be tough to lose this game going into
the bullet but
Johnny Hall
but nihal has three candidate well
there's E5 F5 and he's played F5 wow
yeah you guys are you guys are good
chess players
I would have not done fishing before
I know that's like I'm concerned here
I guess there's Rook to D2 with like
massive pressure on F2 I mean that needs
to just be calculated flat out
straightforwardly you know but Queen E2
also comes to mind just unpinning the
queen or maybe even just H3 making some
Luft
or G4
G4 completely unnecessarily being
aggressive
the G4 actually doesn't even look that
bad
okay please no no it did not
he plays H4
oh and it's a good move y'all's gonna
take the F2 Pawn
yeah well I think black is fine
Rook F7 I think ding missed yeah which
is maybe why you had to go G4 but G4
there was still Rook F7 which is
ridiculous
no there wasn't because gf5 EF5 Bishop
C4
now this doesn't quite well
so now Bishop takes E4 the queen is just
going to move away he takes with a pawn
in order to be able to take F2 and but
suddenly it's a pretty strong attack
Bishop D5 good call
yeah Bishop D5 and black is
in Ship Shape here
like is chilling he's gonna take on F2
and take on H4 if he wants white
shouldn't lose with the queen I mean
there should be a way to force Perpetual
but at this point white is not playing
for a win takes in Bishop G5 and E3
wait a second Bishop G5 and E3 and
are we starting to talk about black
playing for a win potentially
oh my God no
how does he do don't even mention it how
does he do it his King looks a little
too weak to be playing for a win but
anything is possible oh my gosh yeah I
mean there's no way it's like losers
uh and queen E6 was actually a super
very circumspect defensive move now
Queen C8 check with a Perpetual I think
is
the only path forward
yeah this is going to be a drawing yeah
Etc
well you could play Queen C7 Queen B8
and even take on A7 with check
but I think black's gonna go up to the
sixth ring
no
wait why did he do that Queen ba Queen
A7 was like two Pawns
strange yeah mutual oversight I think it
was still a draw even without those
pawns because of the power of the E3
Pawn but
maybe nehal's trying to bait him into it
that's completely shocking that he
didn't play Queen B8 Queen A7 what whoa
G4 King takes G4 and The Rook covers the
check on E6 that's unreal and black is
winning there
he's trying to provoke him it's very
clear what nihal is doing he's trying to
get ding low on time again
can you play King F3 here
oh my God
holy
holy smoke H5
what about King G4 and Rook F5 that's a
knee-haul move if I've ever seen one
yeah yeah
okay oh he's trying to run to G6
and at some point he wants to deliver
that check on F2 and knock White's King
away but even if he does that I don't
see a way to make progress there's Queen
D3 though
King H5 he takes A7 oh oh my God E2 no
E2 Queen takes B6
so check and what oh now E2
because the bishop defends The Rook so
you're basically not really risking
there
or is there he's all trying to find the
best version of it
Bishop F oh my god oh
King Defender the king but white has to
start checking now he's gonna flag again
King H7 and he runs and goes G6 and six
oh my God Bishop H4 unreal
that's done it again
unbelievable nihal sarin sacrifices his
Queen for defensive purposes and wins
the final game of the blitz this is just
spectacular
unbelievable it's amazing and ignore the
eval bar there because the position was
indefensible from a technical standpoint
he had two seconds he had to give the
right sequence of diagonal checks but
think back to the moment after Neil
sacrificed his Queen how do you win a
position like that like how is that even
hypothetically possible
yeah I don't know but for ding to miss
Queen B Queen A7 also was uh was quite
unreal yeah I see our scoreboard here is
going a bit nuts nihal has been granted
first he was granted 10 points for that
Victory uh or 11 points to 18 and a half
now he's now he's been given two points
for this Victory and the scoreboard will
not reset so yeah nehal takes a a lead
uh a very very important one-game lead I
believe I don't think it's a two game
two gameplay I swear it's I swear it's
eight and a half seven and a half
um it's a two game lead no no Levy he
won the last game to untie and then he
won this game for the two-point lead I I
apologies apologies yeah yeah sorry
sorry
um I was thrown off by the fact that we
gave him 10 points originally which was
I mean which was cool but unfortunately
that would have put the match Out Of
Reach already so yeah nihal is uh nahal
is up two and we're heading into the
bullet I mean you you can't script this
any better
you absolutely cannot and ding obviously
has a ton of coming back to do and we
will see if he's able to do it before we
go on our final break of the day we want
to remind you to get ready for the
quarter fourth 2022 state of chess.com
coming to you live on December 21st we
have some huge news for the chess
community and the event will be followed
by a Community Q a with none other than
Danny wrench plus a very special guest
will be joining to show the show to talk
about the exciting announcements we're
making and what these announcements mean
for the future of the chess Community
tune in December 21st at 10 A.M Pacific
1pm Eastern right here on twitch.tv
chess well you will not have to wait
long for the conclusion of this epic SCC
match we'll have 30 minutes of one plus
one to decide the outcome of dingley Ren
against nihal sarin after this very
short break stay tuned
[Music]
chess kit is fun Jess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
welcome back to the 2022 speed Chess
Championship we were hoping for an epic
match between dingley Wren and nihal
sarin and guess what we got one
alongside I am Levy Rosman a pleasure
commentating this match for you on this
lucky Levy seat belts fast and this
bullet is going to be one for the ages
amazing match thus far we've had
multiple lead changes it's been only as
close as two games it hasn't gotten any
uh uh it hasn't the margin hasn't gotten
any wider if you will and both guys have
had opportunities to lead by one game by
two games and it's all been tied up as
well we did not anticipate that going
into the bullet in Hell Soren would have
a two-game lead dingley Ren is gonna
have to strike back and he's gonna have
to strike back emphatically
he is and as we take a quick look at
their Blitz insights before we jump into
the bullet what has been the X Factor
what has been the main determining
factor in the lead that nehal currently
holds well that is an indisputable
question because the answer is clearly
dangleren's losses by flag not taking
anything away from mehals his play has
been incredible he has set himself up
for success but Levy those three or four
points that Ding left on the table in
time scrambles they're gonna come back
to bite him if he ends up losing this
match
yeah they will I think he's lost
like something like 33 probably of his
games uh in in in just the last you know
10 seconds of a match so the thing about
bullet though is that you start with a
minute you do not start with five and
then dwindle down to one and still have
to kind of keep that and you just gotta
play fast
so
and something that Robert likes to point
out by the way oh sorry let me continue
no no I I you're you're fine I think
there's like a for some reason there's
like a delay between our voices so I was
actually all done speaking you can go
ahead okay so as the game kicks off
Robert likes to point out that the
players who struggle to manage their
time in the longer time portions are
sometimes play as if they've been shot
out of a cannonball in the bullet so I
think ding is actually going to manage
this time well here uh the key again is
to avoid the all-out time scrambles and
in the early going he's doing just that
he's got more time that he started with
and some nice preparation against the
London here by the Chinese Grandmaster
now E5 wow just busting open the center
of the board
I wonder what the idea is after Queen E5
for white what do you what do you do
there you try to trade the Queens
I can see Yak we need to and with every
trade the power of White's Knight
increases so ding doesn't even think
about it but now let's get these holes
on the light squares and black is a
pretty big initiative in the early going
yeah Knight C6
the hell does in fact spot that The Rook
was hanging uh yeah surprise maybe
there's an opportunity there to
I I still I still think that in the long
run this is a nightmare to play with
black
yeah just reminds me of Wesley's
positions yesterday against noidder back
when he just had to isolated pawn and
slowly pressuring pressuring and
ultimately winning
no that's a great comparison and it just
you just have to burn a lot of clock to
figure out ways to keep the fire of your
initiative stoked
and G4 by the way is not out of the
question as a way to try to trap this
bishop it's a risky bullet move and
Uhaul prefers to play this more
positionally which I like
things are getting very unpleasant
already for black
also strikes me as a game you can kill
for four minutes in and then win and
then be up three games
yep
yeah these 30 minutes evaporate so
quickly G4
yeah G4 looks
like she really wants to play
he's calculating it but he's now down to
16 seconds not that he ever cares he
just takes the Knight on C4 okay oh and
Knight B5
the other night's going to move into D4
okay that goes to D4 some good
rookie two and grasp on the position
here this this is a disaster for dingley
run
yeah the two reasons you pointed out no
winning chances and this is going to
take a ton of time off the match clock
yep
he's losing his Pawns
really really bad sign for ding he's
gonna he's about to go down three games
night
yeah B5 is now bringing up it's not over
obviously I mean black still has drawing
chances but just all pawn down in a
bullet game I don't see him pulling this
out
nice also good a knight ca3 though
what defense ca3
great call stopping Bishop C2
yep and now night before and the other
night
the other night will now go to B5 yep
and maybe bring the King around to D2
by the way King C4 was not a threat
there was B3 there maybe uh yeah oh my
God
yeah it is almost made
a match clock continues to take down
this game is going to take a long time
wow it's gonna be a full-on end game I
mean no questions asked yep some F4
maybe four minutes already off the clock
and this game is not even close to done
nope
a worse nightmare scenario here for ding
who's gonna lose five minutes on this
game and he might straight up be down 10
and a half seven and a half
you might although he's got good driving
chances if he can hold this together and
he needs to prevent his King from
getting pushed away
uh oh and he can't King D4 white making
progress
yep
C5 Bishop B3 though
but you can in a bullet game you're
gonna drop a pawn eventually Knight C3
Knight T5 oh that's a decisive maneuver
foreign wow four and a half minutes off
the clock and nihal sarin has broken
through it is now a three-game lead for
the first time in the match
and this next game I
don't like to Hype things up falsely but
this actually might be the deciding game
of the match you lose another one with
white and you're staring down the barrel
of a four-point deficit
if you win you bring it down to two and
ding was playing sufficiently fast Levy
I don't think that was the problem he
just got outplayed I mean he flat out
got outplayed
and he's repeating the same line
yes oh my gosh E4 Bishop back to A8
and nihal said hey I'll start an
improvement
yes I knew I was gonna say in the Hall's
gonna happily sacrifice the queen he did
it once He'll Do It Again
you most certainly will but ding ding's
gonna try to go D5 and smash through in
the center
oh I like this Knight D2 ideas A4 for
foreign
I thought Knight H4 was a big
opportunity there to stick that Knight
on F5 that could have been decisive
maybe night okay if he's looking for a
Checkmate can't say I hate it
yes still very unpleasant for black
queen F5 Knight takes D5
maybe wow get away with it Knight takes
D5 Rook D1 or something I'm sure you
can't but it's a bullet game
yeah if nehal doesn't see the refutation
he will play it he also could have Maybe
started with Bishop takes D5 but a
bishop F6 is always an idea now
maybe double on the e-file 95 it's it's
easy to make improving moves here I love
Knight H4 I think this is the this is
the the All-Star idea in this position
uh oh this is winning
this is went up
this is winning in quickly too that's
the problem
yep
rookie three I mean he's just gonna mate
him
rookie three and don't even have to rush
and the most depressing thing is that
black doesn't even have like a pawn to
suffer for like if you had sacked a
piece to get this position okay but
materials equal Knight takes H6 is a
massive threat
if you're black
where
yeah exactly
whoa yeah
I mean I think nehal has yeah you're
right that was ridiculous
it just I'm getting those vibes and
let's see if Dean can keep time on his
clock
oh he blundered Knight F4
oh my how does this guy do it man H5 H5
that's the move ding Mist he's losing
that is unbelievable
how is he doing this white has nothing
nothing
at all yeah ding can't believe it he's
looking at age seven where's my head
five
oh you can just take it oh my God
no and back to F4 for he wants more
now I have five
holy smoke oh my God he just wins the
house he wins the house
he wins the house he gets more time off
the match clock again
Yep this is ridiculous it's not over yet
though there was Bishop F3 in that
position Knight H3 mate oh my God
you won
that's unbelievable four-game lead now
for nehal sarin plenty of time for ding
but he's got to win positions like that
he he does but the insane thing is that
it wasn't like an obvious blunder he
played natural moves and suddenly he was
just losing
yeah you don't know the eval bar shows
what it shows you just know you're
winning and yep that's
shocking just completely shocking 21
minutes
you know it's not Out Of Reach but the
next two games decide everything
they really do ding basically has to be
perfect from now on and I just want to
say nihal is playing so much better than
he was against Geary I think he's just
taking this more seriously
not that he wasn't okay that's the wrong
word but he's he's just brought more of
his A-game to the bullet segment so far
I mean he takes plenty seriously
correction he doesn't think here he's a
serious opponent is what you're saying
that's what I heard whether Twitter
um but no I listen
I concur
um not about the seriousness of the
English giri match but rather
yeah this is uh
now someone is playing lights out
against dangly Wren right now
but he has to avoid getting into the
defensive mindset where oh I'm just
going to milk the clock and the results
of the game doesn't matter Wesley so
almost paid the price for that yesterday
I think he just has to go for the throat
go for another win and
you know just get to a situation where
you don't even have to worry about oh
you know I got a milk this amount of
time off the clock and I think he's
doing that
I agree and his position here is
quite nice although he's not down on
time which does not work in his favor we
all know that nehal
must be down on time to fully activate
you know exactly uh don't worry
he will Rectify that situation Pronto
there we go and now he can start playing
and another time scramble and ding just
isn't able to pull these games out takes
a knight D4 looks interesting
oh Knight D4 is just
black is getting no closer to winning
this game that's a good move though I
like that nope before though it is a
great move attack me too you know
I think B4 shuts it all down
you know it's going to be another super
long game
yeah if ding doesn't win this game it's
probably over
uh just kidding well you should stay
here until the end
just thank you should stay here until
the end regardless
but yes you're being objective I think
ding is good winning chances here Bishop
E6 he's got the bishop here and that
Rook on A6 can move into A3
yeah and it does
okay take beef I don't understand
this is not the way to play for a win
oh what is ding doing no
you're not gonna win the opposite called
Bishop end game come on no oh gosh oh
this is gonna take an hour
diopsis
this will take one hour to finish
opposite colored Bishops is a worst case
scenario ding's trying to ding's trying
to get in the game decline nihal
declined the draw which is an incredibly
smart move actually like you can milk
another minute off the clock if you
wanted
here
as you should and you should sexy for
like if you were to do this properly
oh dang has to be careful because he's
not an experienced premover
no I'm getting really worried No No I
is nehal gonna just Shuffle no I mean by
the way just Chad's understands like
nehal is 100 Justified here I mean
officially I'm completely Justified
because this is the match like this is
thousands of dollars why would you give
your opponent any time on the clock this
is exactly what you should do you
shouldn't and and you should ask yeah go
ahead and you should ask yourself like
do you want to see the players you know
playing for the win playing for
everything that's the spirit of Chess
and yeah it might not be pretty
it might not be the the most fun thing
to watch but you're supposed to play to
win the match and he's doing it he's
built up 36 seconds on his clock and he
can take unlimited time off the match
clock here
not not not anymore
uh not anymore because actually in fact
in fact nihal could sacrifice his pawns
for a draw and ding should not take them
because that would reset the 50 move
rule
so yeah nihal got an extra two minutes
off the clock there you saw ding smiling
because he just
yeah ding has to win and he knows when
now
and that's completely Justified that's
exactly what you should do there
wow
okay still a four point lead and we've
got only half of the bullet portion
remaining
this ain't looking good for Mr Ding and
he goes back to one E4
he goes back to E4 but now nehal is
playing nehal is playing E5
yeah I was like wait is are we sure that
Ding is playing white here and D5 like
Neil is literally channeling his inner
ding
yeah he's playing like Marshall style
although Knight takes C3 is obviously a
threat it's not really a martial style
but I mean listen you need a game to go
for a long time and probably not lose
it's E4 E5 all the way yep
and um yeah
we have a comment on the screen that
said nihal could have been very mean
there yeah he could have gone probably
another minute but at some point as the
chess player you sort of feel like
ridiculous doing what you're doing and
um
yeah so can't really believe yeah but
and it's not like it's not like he needs
to lose the next games like he's up four
points for goodness sakes and the way
he's been playing there's no reason that
he should lose a single other bullet
game he's just totally in control of
these games even when he's worse it
feels like he's controlling the flow and
he's not really that close to losing
uh but having said that it's never too
late to just throw a game completely in
like 30 seconds and then
you know that's the end of it
um
Queen E4 and
well if you go D4 here with white you're
kind of mating the guys so I wonder what
the hell is going to do
and the issue is that G6 does give up
the H6 Pawn so Rook B2 D4 things getting
spicy here oh Jesus
no Bishop F5 yeah
which is sort of a threat I mean the
Knight hangs on C6 but you want to
eliminate this bishop at all costs the
thread is e takes D4
oh my God and ding is down to 10 seconds
again and he just hasn't survived these
time scrambles
yeah
oh no nothing you can do Bishop A4 and
what's what's the idea here Queen whoa
Queen D5 muddying the waters good stuff
by ding
DC seems
CD and he's losing losing again
CD it's over yes
or Bishop C6 oh apparently no that was
wrong now the bishop oh no niho missed
Bishop takes E1 but he might still win
Queen D1
that's a try it's completely oh Queen do
you want queens of the bishop oh my god
he has to take the free pieces in he's
gonna win again no he's not I mean ding
is gonna win
yes not again but he will win but uh
right it was I didn't know how I wanted
to phrase that sentence but it's I mean
Will he win by the way yeah exactly Neo
he's pulled off crazier comebacks than
this position okay if ding doesn't win
this
yeah well he he must I mean it's
but it's still gonna take at least
another minute
it should at least and if nehal can
build up some time
oh blockade oh The Rook is trapped
Rockets
oh King B3 yeah dislodging information
the bishop is blocking A7 though
yes
okay not no it's not
A7
uh by the way one more time off the
clock
yes he should
13 minutes left on the match clock
it's unmateable
okay he's gonna stall out the time and
then play a move right at the last
second
or just that okay
all right okay
what's the layout ding has to be perfect
I don't even think he can afford a draw
yeah I I think it has to be ideal
we're talking about draw not a game
talking about draw no no no drops
um
if he wins this one and there's nine
minutes left on the clock I mean it's
still just it's it's tremendous amount
of time anything can happen in bullet
but
that was so yeah and I mean
you'll probably co-sign this point
um
like when you're leading by like two or
three points and you're looking at the
match clock it just starts moving at a
glacial pace you're like we just played
the longest game ever and it only took
one minute off the clock so the worst
thing to do is to start compulsively
checking the match clock I've uh
butchered a bunch of big leads doing
just that because then you stop playing
the position you know what I'm saying
I in my experience going into bullet
portions I've never been leading like
against Eric or against like any time
I've played one of these matches so at
some point in the bullet I've made the
match very close and I've been cognizant
of the time uh but yes definitely I
remember I took the lead against Eric
and I realized there's one game left and
I just I mean I just lost my mind and
played like the worst game of my life
because I was like what was the last
game and then I just lost and we had to
go to overtime so no it's such it's such
an unsettling feeling
it's not easy yet to know that you're
actually playing with an expiring timer
he's going to lose again
yeah four-game lead insurmountable with
10 minutes on the clock just not
possible the problem is DC there's
Knight to E5 and The Rook on C6 is
simply trapped he needs a miracle in
this game to pull it out
yeah and he hasn't lost yet he's losing
but he hasn't lost so no who has a pawn
for the exchange some good nights it's a
game
he's not having a good night
oh 95 brutal and DC is can he just
resigns oh he's just he just resigns
it's back to four ten and a half minutes
on the clock he's got to win this game
in like 90 seconds which
uh good luck
against yeah the first game took took
four and a half minutes off the clock if
that happens then it's totally a moot
point
Ash what a what a smooth performance in
the latter stages of the three plus one
and in the bullet he's just a buzzsaw
it's in the SEC it's crazy
he's so good
yeah nehal is amazing
I mean he's gonna be ding twice in like
a year in matches come on
oh wow
speaking of clash performances Croatia
just scored on the 126 minute of a match
to tie it against Brazil it looks like
we're going to penalties yeah man oh it
was it scored in overtime oh my God yeah
so Brazil was leading with like three
minutes left and
amazing okay but don't tell me the score
because I'm going to watch the penalties
as a recording on YouTube so nobody in
the chat
sure
I close the chat
and well I have it open for any of the
time to check the morsels of wisdom that
are being shared ah yes they are
spectacularly wise and
they're Mo they mostly just insult me to
get reactions they get they get
reactions every like 30 minutes it's
they love you you could you could dude
you could
don't go this far okay but you could
have like a crazy Arc where you start
going on talk shows and saying wild
stuff not anti-semitic but you know just
crazy things like a unicorns invented
chess and whatever they would love you
say whatever you want you're good you
know
don't uh yeah don't stress about it too
much I won't test it I won't test it no
don't test it don't test it but if you
ever do just know that you know you have
that safety net by the way I just
realized how hopeless this really is
um this game is nowhere near finishing
and we have eight and a half minutes
left it's a four game lead I just I
can't see it up
I think there was a tactic there with
Bishop takes G7 or Rook takes D6 but
yeah ding just needs to score goals
within like a minute and it's not
possible
just does not lose games fast ever
nope
nope nope nope even here
it looks like he's lost but he's gonna
take another two minutes off the match
clock
yeah and let's not forget I mean ding
also has 20 seconds that also counts and
he's gonna think because he
you do
well he just blundered H5 and he might
even lose this game yeah it was okay yep
G6 which has been that kind of match I
mean nehal is wow
that right there was a super practical
decision he gives up his piece but he
says hey we're going into an end game
and it's gonna take you forever to win
and I've got three pawns for the piece
so buckle in
this one looks like it's over
King F2 and
another like two minutes Are Gonna Leave
the match clock man like it's this is
gonna take forever
and the one second bonus adds so much
time
I don't mean it's crazy but yeah it
somehow it
just takes so long
well because if you do the calculations
briefly and it doesn't seem that way but
listen like two seconds are added per
move for each player
if an additional like 40 moves are made
that's like two more minutes which is
huge when the clock comes down like this
it also prolongs the game
yeah yeah
it's not worse
it's probably point three point four
seconds to even like I don't know to
register the move to the server like I'm
sure there's a little bit of like lag
and everything I mean it's yeah
we have to discuss as uh
uh he might lose some time he's gonna
win this game
F4 yeah
he's just out playing him a piece down
just another day in the office for
nehals are in G3 f3h3 gh3h2h1 we in the
mix H6
don't hang a rook though no he doesn't
oh
it's just been the story of the match
one of the sub stories not to reduce it
down to flagging
but um I mean yeah that's not why nehal
won this match he won this match because
he's just straight up the better player
and and uh not maybe not overall but
definitely today and
he has now beaten dingley Wren in Blitz
he has beaten him in bullet and he has
beaten him in Rapid isn't that insane
like
hello nihal sarin are we talking about
Eric icy gukash Prague nehal just
low-key been
emerging as the best speed player out of
India by far it's not even close he's
definitely I think cementing his
position as a top five Blitz and bullet
player overall I mean obviously Hikaru
Magnus
occupy number one and number two but by
a country mile but you know let's also
not forget that Niha has been
maintaining 3200 Blitz on chess.com now
for many months
and he's doing it against many different
opponents he never gets crushed like the
consistency and the speed he's just got
the right combination of qualities
and it makes him just a nightmare
opponent even when he's not in the
greatest form and this is where Anish is
really kicking himself he had the best
chance that anybody might have against
nehal this season in the SEC
I know yeah and then I mean the comeback
was just perfect I
I I felt for a niche I I really did for
sure not that I'm ever
cheering for you know anyone to win or
lose but it's just amazing I mean
yeah yeah
well he all has the white guy in here he
makes the clock a five-point lead to
boot
and he's not stopping here oh he Mouse
slipped oh
oh
well we got four minutes to kill before
we probably invite nihal for an
interview anything anything you want to
ask him
um well he's I mean he's obviously very
very modest so I struggle I'll be
totally open and honest and say I
struggle to ask good questions in these
interviews because the players
they're tired you know they're not
always in the mood to expand upon their
strategy but I definitely want to ask
about openings
you know I wish I could know what his
secret was I wish he could verbalize it
but then we'd all be as good as nihal
sarin
yep
it's true
we gotta ask him who he's rooting for in
the World Cup
oh obligatory question it would not be
an interview
without it
I I I can see nehal just casually not
knowing there's a World Cup going on
just doing this thing just playing chess
preparing for tournaments
World Cup isn't happening until until a
year from now
yeah he'll be like what World Cup
there's Chess World Cup 2023.
um you know the craziest thing for a guy
like nihalis he might not even play at
the World Cup of Chess because he never
qualified like I don't exactly know how
you qualify
uh I'm sure he will but
qualification is a weird
thing for the World Cup in chess
yeah yeah it is it is and qualification
is different based on like where you are
and the tournaments that you're playing
now it's it's interesting that nihal's
classical rating by the way is still
like 26.50 I mean
it I know he doesn't win these games
because of Blitz specific skills like he
outplays people regularly classical
Style
but why would you play you know bladder
that open in some random city in Europe
to gain a ELO when you can play against
England of the speeches championship and
get to the semi-finals and you win like
seven thousand dollars eight thousand
like I mean you know what I mean like
it's really why would you I mean in
chess to become uh like a full-time
professional In classical you need to be
invited and you need to be playing as a
top 20 player if you're like eight 70th
in the world like nihalas he just won
fifty thousand dollars in cgc who the
hell needs classical chess the whole
classical chess kind of career is just
completely broken it just doesn't make
sense for guys like me how to focus on
but he will in the long run for sure and
he he does he still does and I think
classical chess is still very respected
but what I love is that you know it used
to be the case that you would always put
an asterisk next to oh he's good at
Blitzer he's good at rapid oh well that
doesn't really matter it's just online
Blitz now you know those skills are
rewarded handsomely and they're put onto
the pedestal for everybody to see and
the skill in Blitz as nihal delivers on
another game is a full-fledged skill not
to be necessarily compared to classical
they're different games they're
different skills but both of them allow
you to further uh what has been you know
thus far an amazing career for knee
Holland what will continue to be an
illustrious career I'm sure
listen uh whether fans or fellow
colleagues of nihal sarin will say that
he is not actually you know as strong as
he is because classical is the
epitome of chest strength uh nehal will
laugh all the way to the bank and say
he's out earned 99.99 of chess players
already in their entire careers and he's
only 18 years old and if nihal ever gets
invited to a top level event like Tata
steel I don't know if he's playing in
the open I don't think he is but he
might I think he is this uh
he'll win it too like all right you want
me to prove myself in classical I'll win
that too no problem you know what I mean
but
uh I I don't think he is right I think
they invited like gukesh and Eric I see
to the Masters but I don't think he's
there yeah they invited gukesh every
guys he won the Challenger section But
Eric icy has just been unbelievable I
mean the talent coming out of India
right now is is pretty next level
and definitely if you think about Arjun
World Championship material for sure
but knocked out round one against Fabio
would nihal have beaten Fabiano I mean
you know in Toronto full disclosure I
said nihal is the third likeliest player
to win this event behind Magnus and
Hikaru that is not an like exaggeration
statement No you're totally right and
for a while I think people were too
influenced by his classical rating but
now everybody sees that
you know his place in the in the SCC is
is you know the sac wouldn't be complete
without him there's players like ikara
Magnus Niha has to be included in that
in that conversation where you know like
this tournament is really only complete
if he's playing given his past
performances okay this is officially
officially going to be the last game the
hall offers a draw which dig declines
he's like no I want to win the last game
I want to score the honor goal
yeah it makes sense he wants to end on a
on a win I mean it's a pricey win I
think it's like three four hundred
dollars
um yeah and I don't remember the
preceding I don't remember if nehal was
the fourth seed or the fifth seed but in
my eyes he was the third seed in this
event
um
and I I don't even think he's such a
huge I would love to see nehal versus
Magnus I mean that would be fascinating
because we've seen nahal Hikaru like
we've seen them play for fun
but we have almost never seen Magnus
nihal I feel like and I mean they play
for fun as well in Blitz but we've seen
it much less than Hikaru so
God that match strap yourselves in and I
mean obviously in that match I think
niho will have to bring his A-game
opening wise and in so far as you can
discuss areas of improvement definitely
in the matches he struggled in a lot of
it has had to do with his opening play
even today I mean if you think about the
start of the match ding was firing on
all cylinders in the opening and then
somehow as the match moved to a shorter
time control nihal was able to dilute
those issues with his incredibly
accurate middle game play but
nonetheless something to chew on
and yeah and once again
and yeah and I was gonna say and once
again in another match he's just
unbelievable defensively he had one or
two games this match that he's safe from
what the computer evaluated as a
completely lost position so it seems
even more crazy but
yeah I mean it was like mate yeah it was
another yeah we were right it was like
the Savion game and
and it's funny I mentioned that and then
the moment after that Ding blundered
yep yeah and that's how it works
nihal might just repeat moves here or he
might go for the win
I think ding is likely to flag here
oh with one second
oh Bishop B3 such a devilish little move
in time pressure
oh
he's gonna give a bunch of Bishop the
game still goes
yeah just end it ah the matingness mate
oh brutal absolutely brutal and nihal
wins the last game to end the match up
eight points but obviously Levy it goes
without saying if you watched anything
other than the bullet you know that that
doesn't tell the whole story it was a
close match
yeah and that's it and that's it I mean
smarter chess got one thing wrong in
this match
and that was the bullet and it just
never ever got I mean nehal sarin very
well might be on a good day the best
bullet player in the world like on a
good day I'm sorry I know we got
magazine Hikaru I'm talking on a good
day
all star and proof today that
he is incredible and that Anish Geary
bullet segment might have just been a
fluke
and he has made a strong case for that
in his match against sting listen it was
a valiant effort by dangly Wren somebody
who lacks quite as much experience in
online chess he had his incredible
moments but at the end of the day Hall's
consistency his grit his resilience in
bad positions and obviously his speed
Above All Else once again move him
through to the round of four to the
semi-finals folks before we go on a
break and bring the hall in for an
interview please uh right in chat what
questions you want to ask nihal we
cannot promise to ask all of them but we
will select a couple of chat questions
to ask me Hall in the interview and on
that note here at the 22 2022 speed
chess championship week we'll be back
with the victor of today's match for an
interview nihal star and will be in the
studio on the other side of this short
break
foreign
ER Danny wrench Chief chess officer back
again with more chess terms here for you
today we're going to talk about the past
Pawn the past Pawn must be pushed you
hear it said often and that's because
just about every end game you see that
isn't a blowout often comes down to
maybe someone's up one Pawn or maybe
even just the first person to create a
past Pawn is the person who goes on to
win that game we're going to talk about
what the past Pawn is and to find it for
you in today's video let's do it what is
a past Pawn a past Pawn is a pawn that
has no enemy pawns stopping it from
moving forward that means pawns either
on the file in which it resides or on
the adjacent files that would therefore
capture the pawn should it advance so if
a pawn has none of those things stopping
its way then it's time to push them baby
as our boy Yasser would say and as you
hear mentioned on many broadcasts that
you would watch on chess TV and on that
note as we look at our game examples we
like to do this is taken from Thomas
chefsky versus rajaba here white plays
the move B5 5x claim which highlights
again it's not how many pawns you have
but who's going to be threatening to get
a queen first after black takes it white
pushes forward with gusto and because
the Rook can't blockade the pawn due to
the light Square Bishop this game is
already over black is going to have to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn on B6
and white would simply be up a minor
piece note that after the first move B5
should a takes B5 have been played white
would have pushed this pawn and then
trap The Rook on A7 showing the power of
the pass Pawn as with it protecting the
bishop this Rook is completely out of
the game and white would easily go on to
win picking up pawns and just flexing
the rook's muscles over the bishop for
the rest of the game so here we see a
pass Pawn being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a pass Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
everything
laughs
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everybody to the speed
Chess Championship
um it seems that in Newhall interview
just isn't meant to be he just had some
technical issues joining the call we did
our absolute best we promise but
unfortunately we're going to have to
pass on the nehal interview today but
nonetheless we got all of the
entertainment we could possibly ask for
today it's been amazing covering the
match so let's wrap up with a couple of
announcements and observations to start
let's take a one more look at the
bracket as it currently stands Levy
Rosman nihal sarin is our first
semi-finalist and what would the SEC be
without nihal sarin in the semis
I know spectacular stuff really and he
awaits the winner of Nakamura versus
aranyan and obviously the favorite there
being Hikaru we might get a Hikaru
versus nihal sarin uh potential
semi-final matchup which would be the
final match up in 99 out of 100
tournaments of speech Yes but uh sadly
that's not to be and that Hikaru match
speaking of which is coming up on Monday
December 12th so get your fix of Chess
boxing on December 11th and then we
resume the SEC
indeed that's coming your way 12 p.m
noon Pacific 3 P.M
eastern time as Hikaru faces Lavon
aronian and Lavon obviously will have to
bring his a plus plus game for that
match speaking of a plus game another
event that you should put on your
calendar the day after the Hikaru
aronian match Tuesday December 13th is
your chance to play chess against sports
legends Larry Fitzgerald and Gordon
Hayward in the first ever collab stream
between these two chess fans players
will battle Fitzgerald and Hayward in a
rapid time control Arena and all of the
action will be streamed live on Gordon's
twitch channel to become eligible and
join the arena on Game Day head on over
to go.chess.com play Gordon that's
go.chess.com play Gordon and join Gordon
hayward's chess.com Club
drop exclamed Legends exclamed Legends
in the chat for a direct link so more
fun to come next week more SEC action
and the super fun event featuring sports
legends Larry Fitzgerald and Gord and
Hayward so on that note ladies and
gentlemen the time has come for us to
wrap up today's coverage of the speed
Chess Championship we congratulate nihal
sarin on another incredible incredible
effort Levy before I wrap up I'll pass
it back to you one more time for your
final observations
my observations are that every time we
see nihal sarin the level is elevated he
was stopped short in Toronto by a
juggernaut of an opponent and
unfortunately uh he just couldn't quite
seal the deal but against uh dingley run
today the level was palpable I mean he
bounced back multiple times sealed it in
the faster Blitz format the bullet was
just the most lopsided he's had in a
while and I'm just so excited to see
where he goes next unfortunately speed
chess has two Final Bosses and their
names are hikara Nakamura and Magnus
Carlson you can choose who you think is
the true final boss but those two are
the final two the uh the the they wait
at the gates to see if you really are
Elite at the format and Dania I'm I'm
just pumped to see this next matchup of
Hikaru Levon uh you're probably going to
be calling it and if not then well we'll
see I'll probably be seeing you soon as
well and it was a pleasure working with
you today
likewise it always is Levy I'd like to
thank everybody in the chat who decided
to watch the SEC maybe in parallel or
rather than the football match which is
the best decision you can make the next
match comes your way on Monday we wish
everybody a great weekend and Levy thank
you to you always a pleasure working
with you thank you to our amazing
production team for yet another Flawless
broadcast on that note we wish you a
great weekend ladies and gentlemen from
the speed Chess Championship
International Master Levy Rosman and GM
Daniel nerdinsky bidding you a great
rest of your day we'll see you on Monday
for Hikaru versus aronian so long
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you